Herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Prüttlerf.
Wir sollten mal wieder am Ärger haben, Max reden.
So, jetzt hab ich's aber. Ihr wisst, wo ihr seid. Not safe for work, Tim und Holgi.
Tim, du machst mir Angst.
Ihr hört CRI Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Prüttlerf.
Wir können euch mal kurz rausschicken, weil ich frische Luft schnappte.
This time it's Tim Prüttlerf opening this wonderful program.
Wir fliegen gleich Marthe Flaschen, Tim.
Unsere Hörerzeit roppt.
Ist ja gut. Hier ist der Lautsprecher, ja, wieder mit Gas. Ja, wo sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich?
Keine Ahnung.
Rückwiss ohne ich.
Und wo sind Huckel?
Denis.
Oh mein Gott. Denis und Huckel sind gemorft in ihren neuen Avatar. Und den haben wir jetzt eingeladen.
Super. Tach.
Roddi, aber dich muss man eigentlich gar nicht mehr vorstellen, weil du warst ja schon mal da.
Ja, die Leute kennen mich.
Genau.
Ach, Roddi wieder.
Du hörst ja schon wieder.
Immer das gleiche. Ja, Huckel kann nicht und Denis ist kränklich. Dementsprechend reduzierte und veränderte Besetzung, aber das macht ja nix. Und trotz alledem haben wir hier wieder ein, wie soll man sagen, ein lustiges Potpourri an tollen Informationen.
Schreibt man das mit D in dem Fall?
Potpourri ist das Wort, was ich immer wieder nachsage, wie man es sagt. Es gibt bestimmt einen Podcast, der so heißt.
Ja, und ich sag niemals so.
Also bei Podcasts sind eigentlich schon alle Wortwitze durch, hab ich so den Eindruck.
Wie bei Friseuren.
Genau. Das denk ich auch immer wieder, immer wieder.
Und dann kommt der nächste Friseur.
Ja, ist nicht so einfach mit den Namen, wie man ja hier schon im Einstieg gemerkt hat. Wie immer, ich bin nicht schuld, sondern David ist schuld, der hier immer die großartigen Intros macht und auch immer wunderbar getimt. Einen Tag vor der Sendung landet das bei mir in der Inbox. Ja, was soll ich sagen?
Super.
Genau, super. Hat auch einen Flatterknopf. Ist auf unserer Homepage, jedes Mal.
Jetzt draufdrücken.
Genau. Ja, ansonsten können wir uns ja hier wieder unserem Fanboyism hingeben.
Nein. Nicht? Nein.
Warum nicht jetzt? Heute haben wir Scoops. Soviel kann man schon mal sagen.
Das ist die 80. Sendung. Wir hatten alles schon mal. Genau, das stimmt.
Das ist die 80. Sendung. Ihr seid nämlich beim Movamex, Ausgabe 80, um das auch mal gesagt zu haben.
In 80 folgen um den Mac.
Genau. Und da wir ja auch immer gerne mal wieder über Macs reden, werden wir das auch dieses Mal tun. Allerdings denke ich mal, fangen wir vielleicht mal da an, was so unmittelbar nach unserer letzten Sendung geschah. Wollen wir da chronologisch vorgehen?
Quasi in Reaktion auf unsere Sendung war das ja.
Ja, die unmittelbaren Auswirkungen.
Warten auf den Cupertino zu spüren.
Ja, das sind die seismischen Auswirkungen des Podcastings. Ja, meine Frage war, sollen wir da chronologisch durcheiern?
Wie du willst.
Wie ich will, ja. Ich fragte ja nun nicht.
Ach, ich dachte du sprichst mit dir selbst.
Ich wüsste sowieso nicht, was zuerst kam.
Wenn ich wollte, würde ich ja nicht fragen.
Ja komm, mach die Quartalszahlen. Dann haben wir es hinter uns.
Erst die Quartalszahlen?
Ja.
Okay, das ist aber nicht chronologisch, ne?
Nein, nein, das ist aber...
Wie in jeder guten Keynote kommt zuerst die Quartalszahlen.
Genau, okay, das ist natürlich ein gutes Leitmotiv. Also, and the winner is... Ja, ich meine, also eigentlich ist das ja hier so ein bisschen e-Pretty-to-the-converted und davon abgesehen dürfte das ja nun wirklich jeder mitbekommen haben, weil das war schon ein bisschen absurd, oder? Also es kam jetzt nicht unbedingt unerwartet, aber es war auf jeden Fall absurd. Als dann Heise mit der Meldung kam, wie gut das Quartal gelaufen ist und dann so ein paar Vergleiche aufgestellt hat, da wurde mir dann doch schon ein bisschen schwummerig.
Na, ich hab irgendwie im Vorfeld, hab ich gehört, dass es das erste 30 Milli... also mir ziemlich sicher das erste 30 Milliarden Umsatzquartal in der Geschichte von Apple wird. Und dann hat irgendwie ein Tag vorher so... ich glaub hier Paris-Ländern, Lemon, also MG Siegler so, ja ja, ich hab auch gehört, das könnte auch das erste 40 Milliarden Quartal werden.
Also hast du sie noch alle? Was ich sehr lustig fand, war diese Zusammenstellung, wo jemand geguckt hatte, alle Quartale von allen Firmen je. Und unter den ersten 20 war als einzige Nicht-Öl- und Gas-Company Apple. Also die anderen 18 Plätze waren alles Öl- und Gas-Companys.
Also die anderen 18 nach, also die sind ja...
Nee, die waren da irgendwo auf Platz 10 oder so. Nee, auf Platz 2 oder auf Platz 3.
Es gab nur ein Quartal, nämlich das von Exxon, und das auch zum Zeitpunkt des Höhepunktes des Ölpreises, wo es ihnen mal besser ging.
Vor oder nach der Valdez?
Das war 1998, also, nee, entschuldigung, nicht 1998, das war 2005.
Ich glaube 2005.
Nicht so lange her. Das kenne ich mir im Ölpreis aus.
Unser Metier sind ja Apple, das sind ja Technologie-Firmen, Quartalzahlen, die wir auswendig runterrattern können.
Ja, in so Mac ist auch nicht viel Öl drin, oder?
Ach, das würde ich jetzt mal nicht sagen. Wobei Kunststoff ist schon gar nicht mehr so viel dabei.
Hängt davon ab, wie viel man oben reinkommt.
Bestenfalls noch in der Verpackung. Schon krass.
2008 meint jemand.
Wir sind ja nicht dafür bekannt, dass wir jetzt besonders gut recherchiert hätten. Wir meinen halt immer. Ja, 2008, genau. Und was ich dann aber auch interessant fand, ist, dass... Entschuldigung, ich bin gerade unkonzentriert, weil ich hier gerade versuche, diese Informationen zu finden. Und irgendwie finde ich sie gerade nicht an der Stelle, wo ich dachte, dass ich sie finde. Wie auch immer, ich fand diesen Vergleich, den Heise gemacht hat mit Microsoft und mit IBM ganz beeindruckend, dass das beste Quartal von Microsoft war halt die Hälfte.
Gewinn oder Umsatz?
Das bezieht sich, das sagen sie hier gar nicht, aber ich glaube, das bezieht sich auf, ja, super. Wieso fragst du so was nach? Das lässt mich nur scheiße dastehen in diesem Podcast. Das ist mein Job. Boah, ja, hier Tim und so. Was der immer wieder auskriegt. Dieses Fachwissen. Und dann sowas. Belanglosigkeiten.
Wir sagen es nicht.
Ich glaube, es bezieht sich auf den Gewinn.
Das zusammengefasste Quartal war fett.
Es war fett. Und IBM hat das auch noch nicht hinbekommen.
Das hat niemand. Das muss Umsatz gewesen sein. Vom Gewinn her wären die ja in dieser Top 20 drin gewesen.
Der Vergleich mit Exxon ist auf Basis des Gewinns. Der Gewinn bei Exxon lag bei 14 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Aber Umsatz haben wir gigantisch viel mehr.
Umsatz ist auch wirklich immer so eine Sache. Es gibt halt Branchen, die mit extrem viel Umsatz arbeiten. Und nicht so viel Gewinn daraus holen.
Die Computerbranche zum Beispiel.
Ja, Apple muss halt viel mehr bauen. Hat ganz andere Kosten. Trotzdem machen sie halt so viel Kohle. Softwareindustrie.
Ich glaube, es gibt nicht viele. Das ist eine andere Geschichte. Ich finde, ein Drittel von dem, was wir umgesetzt haben, ist dann als Gewinn hinten rausgefallen.
Das ist für ein Hardware-Hersteller aber schon ziemlich viel.
Das ist schon ziemlich viel. Ich glaube, die anderen sind alle im 2-3%-Bereich. Vorsichtig ausgedrückt halt. Aber ich glaube, das ist für alle Branchen verdammt viel. Mit Fabergé-Eiern kann man vielleicht...
Also vergleichen wir mal.
Parfüm hat bestimmt ähnlich.
Das beste Quartal von Microsoft. Also Microsoft. Hier gibt es ja diese schöne Webseite. Apples Quartal Results Visualized.
Habt ihr sicherlich auch schon gesehen? Nee, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Hat die Apple Quartal?
Wie hast du nicht gesehen?
Hab ich nicht.
frncs.co.slash.apple frncs.co.slash.apple So eine hübsche JavaScript-Charts, wo man sich da allerlei klicken kann. Unter anderem auch so die ganzen Revenues und Profits von Microsoft und Google und Amazon und Apple im Vergleich. So, und der beste Profit, den Microsoft gemacht hat, war 6,66 Milliarden. Dahingehend, würde ich fast vermuten, bezieht sich das dann doch auf den Revenue. Ja, der war jetzt aber auch gerade irgendwie top. Naja, wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, Apple geht es jetzt nicht unbedingt schlecht. Und was sich da wirklich total abzeichnet, ist ja auch, ist ja kein Ende in Sicht. Oder? Also ich meine...
Jetzt geht es ganz schnell nach unten. Ja, jetzt wo immer so ein Kind auf dem Markt ist, ist mein alles, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Das war's.
Nein, nein, jetzt wo die Kinderkrankheiten von Android alle draußen sind.
Ich hab Android überholt jetzt sozusagen. Ich weiß nicht.
Was ich an den Zahlen... Es gab ja dieses Übliche, was Apple damit alles kaufen könnte. Und ja, und 10 Torten, 10 Milliarden Euro, oder weißt du, was du sagst? Was ich wirklich beeindruckend fand als Einziger von den Zahlen ist, dass Apple könnte mit dem Augenblick mit ihrem Bargeld, ohne sich zu verschulden, könnten die BMW und Mercedes kaufen. Also irgendwie BMW hat es 40 Milliarden wert und Mercedes 44 Milliarden. Oder umgekehrt, ich weiß nicht. Genau, Daimler 44, BMW 40 Milliarden. Bamm, alles beides weg.
Ja, aber das Erstaunliche ist, sowas machen sie halt nicht. Apple kauft keine großen Firmen, weil sie genau wissen, dass das nie alles nur im Elend landet.
Ja, was wollen sie auch mit?
Ja, was sollen sie damit auch?
Steile Autos fahren?
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist natürlich immer so schön, so eine etablierte Marke und so. Aber ich glaube, sie haben es auch derzeit gar nicht nötig, irgendwelche Konkurrenz groß rauszukaufen, weil die machen sich eigentlich sowieso alle selber fertig.
Aber was wollen die mit der Kohle machen?
Naja, was sie damit machen, zeigen sie ja immer wieder. Sie haben ja zum Beispiel vor ein, zwei Monaten, die Nachricht ist jetzt auch schon ein bisschen älter, ich hatte die hier schon mehrfach auf meiner Liste, diese israelische Firma gekauft an Nobit. Die Spezialisten sind im SSD-Bereich.
Flash-Bereich allgemein, schnelles Flash.
Ja, das wollte ich auch sagen. Flash, genau. Ja, das Flash. Und zwar, wie heißen nochmal diese beiden Flash-Typen?
Gibt es diese Multilevel-Cells und diese Single-Cells?
Multilevel und Single-Level, genau. Und die Multilevel sind schneller, aber verbrauchen sich schneller. Und die Single-Level sind halt langsamer, aber halten länger. Und diese Anubits stehen so in dem Ruf, da irgendwie eine Lösung gefunden zu haben, dass sie eben diese Multilevel-Excess-Geschichte machen und dabei aber auch Methoden gefunden haben, dass die sich eben nicht so schnell weichtreten.
Du kannst bei einer Single-Level-Cell halt nur ein Bit in einer Zelle speichern. Wenn du bei einer Multilevel-Cell halt mehrere Bits in einer Zelle speicherst, dadurch, dass du halt zwei hoch N Level verwendest und hast dann entsprechend N Bits in einer Zelle drin. Aber die musst du halt auch wieder auseinander kriegen, die Level, weil wenn das Zeug irgendwie abläuft, dann verändern sich deine Bits. Das ist das Problem.
Und weil ich das verstanden habe, haben die irgendwelche Fehlerkorrektur-Mechanismen am Start oder sonst irgendwelche Approaches. Mir hat sich jetzt kein Dokument so eröffnet, in dem das mal genauer beschrieben wurde. Tatsache ist, sie haben den Laden einfach geschoppt. Und das wird sicherlich nicht billig gewesen sein. Und das ist natürlich genau diese Art von Aquisen, die Apple gerne macht. Und sie wollen jetzt sogar Research and Development da aufmachen in Israel.
Wenn der Laden tatsächlich kann, was er vorgibt zu können, dann war das ja kein schlechter Kauf.
Ja, vermutlich.
Also es macht eh den Eindruck, dass Apple jetzt auch mehr hingeht und seine ganzen Semi-Kontakte das auch selber macht. Weil es müssen sie selber designen. Ich meine, bei der CPU sind sie schon dabei. Früher war es ja auch schon mal so, aber jetzt wird es irgendwie richtig massiv.
Naja, den Kram selber zu machen kann halt ein Vorteil sein oder eine Liability. Also wenn du nicht in der Lage bist, mindestens so gut zu sein, wie das Zeug, das du von der Stange kaufen kannst, dann ist es natürlich blöd. Aber wenn du es schaffst, besser zu sein, als das, was die Konkurrenten von der Stange kaufen können, dann beißen sich die Konkurrenten in den Arsch. Das ist eine ganz normale Sache. Ich meine, guck dir das Beispiel Amiga an. Als sie neu rauskamen, hatten sie ihre Custom Chips. Die waren halt was, was keiner konnte. Und die sind mit der Entwicklung nicht hinterhergekommen. Und ein paar Jahre später war das Zeug nur ramsch und sie mussten irgendwie den Laden dicht machen, weil sie nicht mehr mithalten konnten.
Weil sie es nicht verbessert bekommen haben.
Genau.
Naja, also bisher läuft es ja ganz gut. So mit den Prozessoren und so. Müssen wir mal sehen. Ja, und ansonsten schmeißen sie ihre Kohle natürlich auf die großen Unternehmen. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange Samsung da noch von zehren darf. Die haben sie bestimmt nicht so richtig lieb.
Aber so dieses Prinzip, einfach diese...
Ja, die haben sicherlich ein professionelles Verhältnis, wie man sieht.
Sie verklagen sich gegenseitig so ein bisschen.
Genau, Round the Globe, ohne Ende, ist schon ein bisschen albern. Haben wir jetzt noch nicht so viel drüber geredet, aber ich finde es auch so ein bisschen... Man redet da so ein bisschen über etwas, was man am Ende sowieso nicht versteht, weil welches Patent jetzt wo, wie, gilt oder nicht gilt oder welches Geschmacksmuster wo durchzusetzen ist oder nicht, das wird man dann sehen.
Aber was ich jetzt ganz putzig finde, dass die EU-Kommission jetzt sich quasi eingeschaltet hat und ein Wettbewerbsverstoß, Blablabla-Verfahren gegen Samsung gestaudet hat.
Die EU?
Weil die Samsung hat jetzt angefangen sozusagen als Rückschlag gegen Apple.
Wo ist die News her?
Mal von Heise. Von Heise. Das sollte alles ein bisschen gemütlicher her. Haben sie ja angefangen, Apple zu verklagen, von wegen EU-Wettbewerbsverfahren gegen Samsung. Genau. Haben sie Apple verklagt wegen irgendwelcher UMTS-Patente? So von wegen, die hätte Apple nicht wirklich und weiß ja teuer was und nicht geholt und probiert einen Verkaufsstopp durchzusetzen. Jetzt kam da irgendwie die EU-Kommission, hat jetzt dann gesagt so, ja Moment mal, hat die nicht mal gesagt, dass ihr hier für Telefone diese ganzen UMTS-Patente mit in den Pool schmeißt? Was ist denn das jetzt? Ist das nicht so mal Wettbewerbshemmnis und sowas? Was ich ja ganz knuffig finde. Na ja, mal gucken, wie das weitergeht.
Schmeiß mal den Link in den Chat.
Den Link in den Chat.
Dann hab ich den auch gleich hier notiert. Na gut, lass uns nicht so lange mit so Wirtschaftsgelaber aufhalten. Reden wir lieber über andere Sachen, von denen wir nichts verstehen.
Genau wie bei der Keynote.
Lass uns nicht mit dieser Wirtschaftsgelaber aufhalten. Jetzt reden wir über die Zukunft. Also Apple hat einen Tag nach der letzten Mobamex-Sendung in direkter Reaktion darauf dieses Education-Announcement gemacht und dabei zwei Dinge vorgestellt. Einerseits, dass die Idee eines iBook ein weiteres Mal, ich weiß nicht, wie oft Apple noch iBooks ankündigen möchte.
Das ist jetzt iBooks 2.0.
Ja, aber jetzt gibt es ja wieder was anderes, was iBook heißt.
So ein Markenname, den kann man noch lange pflegen.
Na ja, erst war es ein Computer. Dann war es diese App und dieser Bookstore auch.
Genau, der iBook Store.
Okay, der heißt nicht wirklich iBooks. Aber diese App, die halt EPUB liest und jetzt gibt es halt auch noch das Dateiformat iBook.
Nee, das sind Multitouch-Bücher.
Multitouch-Books.
Das heißt Punkt iBook.
Ja, das ist doch, weil es für die iBook-App ist.
Na und, EPUB ist auch für die iBook-App.
Ja, aber das ist was anderes.
EPUB ist auch für andere Sachen als iBook-App.
Multitouch-Bücher, so heißt das nämlich.
Hast du noch genug Werte, Bäuschen, da drüben eigentlich?
Nein, meine sind aus. Aber vielleicht gibt's mir welche von deinen Ruhestellen.
Hat sich eine ganze Menge Diskussion entfacht rund um die Lizenzbedingungen. Das fand ich auch ganz interessant. Und was Apple da macht, ist, kurz gesagt, sie haben eine App rausgebracht, kostet nichts für den Mac, die heißt iBooks Author, die kann man nehmen und damit kann man ein iBook authoren, wie der Name auch schon nahe liegt. Und das ist dann ein interessantes Konzept, nämlich eine Art lebendiges Buch, sag ich mal, lebendig in zweierlei Hinsicht. Erstens kann es halt, darf ich das Wort sagen, multimediale Daten enthalten.
Wir werden dieses Wort Multimedia nicht mehr lösen.
Es kommt langsam wieder.
Naja, ich meine, jetzt wird's ja langsam auch. Diesmal wirklich.
Ja, genau diesmal.
Diesmal wirklich Multimedia. Okay, lassen wir das. Also Bilder, Filme klar und 3D-Elemente.
So wie hatten wir im L5 oder wie jetzt?
Naja, das war ja dann auch die große Frage, was ist in den Namen? Und ist halt so, dass es sich eigentlich dabei um ein weiteres Dateiformat handelt, aus dieser iWork-Familie. Und das frisst auch direkt Keynote. Du dreckst da deine Keynote-Präsentationen in dein iBook rein und das werden sie dann sicherlich nicht in irgendetwas anderes groß konvertieren, sondern das ist halt da einfach Teil davon.
Finde ich aber interessant, dass das Keynote als Datenquelle genommen wird und nicht so was wie Pages. Also ich würde jetzt, wenn ich ein Buch authoren würde, würde ich ja jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, ich nehme erstmal eine Präsentation und mach die zu einem Buch.
Es geht ja dabei um diese Elemente.
Du kannst die Präsentation reinpappen.
Das ist schon ganz cool.
Das sind so die interaktiven Features. Du liest über irgendetwas und dann hast du so, was weiß ich, die Geschichte der Dinosaurier, blablabla, und dann blätterst du da irgendwie ein Cambrium und tralala.
Und dann kommen da fünf Bullet Points reingeschwemmt.
Du kannst da reinmachen, was du willst. Aber im Wesentlichen ist das halt so das, was da möglich ist.
Powerpoint ist durch.
Ich bin mir sicher, ich hab's nicht ausprobiert, dass du da auch Pages-Dokumente mehr oder weniger reinziehen kannst. Ob er das so direkt liest, weiß ich nicht.
Hab ich nicht ausprobiert. Was ich ganz spannend fand, als kleines, nettes Detail, es mag uns ja allen schockierend sein, aber in Amerika ist es ja mittlerweile geradezu ein Problem, dass das ein Buch nehmen, in dem es quasi um die Evolution geht. So direkt mal als allererstes vorne weg, weil das ist ja in Amerika kein unumstrittenes Thema, so Evolution ernst zu nehmen.
In dem einen oder anderen Staat im Bible-Beld, glaube ich.
Ist das so? Ist das so? Weil ich muss sagen, ich habe bisher in meinem Leben noch kein Multitouch-Buch ausprobieren dürfen, denn ich besitze hier nur iPad 1 und die sind nicht vollständig verreckt. Ich habe dieses Buch da drauf geladen, ich habe dieses iBooks gestartet, habe auf dieses Buch drauf getippt und dann fing irgendwie dieser Film an zu spielen, was ich daran merkte, dass ich den Ton hörte, aber ansonsten blickte ich nur auf diesen Linenhintergrund und sonst nichts.
Oh, das ist ja mal kein guter Start.
Genau, kein guter Start. Also ich habe es auf dem iPad 1 nicht zum Laufen bekommen.
Also ich habe auf dem iPad 2 läuft es okay, aber es kann ruhig noch besser. Also es ruckelt noch ein bisschen an einigen Stellen.
Echt, das ruckelt sogar auf dem iPad 2?
Na, es gibt Momente, in denen könnte es ruhig schneller sein. Also es ruckelt nicht die ganze Zeit, aber zwischendurch hängt es immer mal wieder so ein bisschen. Also das ist noch rough around the edges.
Vielleicht nochmal zu diesem Prinzip.
Vielleicht musst du das kompilieren.
Zu diesem Prinzip des iBooks. Also was ich doch ganz kes finde ist, dass sie die Anforderungen an ein Schulbuch, nämlich dass man so Layout hat und dass die Dinge irgendwie didaktisch angeordnet sind, realisieren in dem Moment, wo du das halt als Landscape-Buch benutzt. Also du drehst halt dein iPad quer und dann hast du eben Layout. Und wenn du es eben in Porträtmodus bringst, dann hast du dasselbe Buch, aber als Fließtext und alles was vorher grafisch positioniert war, schiebt sich als Thumbnail in den Sidebar und ist an der Stelle eben nach wie vor abrufbar. Und das ist eigentlich eine sehr coole Kombination aus eben layoutetem Buch, aber eben auch den Wunsch, den man eigentlich an so einem E-Book hat, nach dem Motto, ja, mach doch mal den von größer. Und jetzt will ich es einfach auch gut lesen können. Und vor allem will ich ihn lesen und jetzt nicht so durchblättern wie durch eine Zeitschrift.
Wir haben vor allen Dingen auch Seitenzahlen. Das find ich ja lustig.
Und vor ein paar Sendungen, als wir hier über diese merkwürdigen Krebsgeschwüre namens Magazin-Apps gesprochen haben, die alle so als Multi-Megabyte-Monsta, Multi-100-Megabyte- oder Gigabyte-Monsta daherkommen und sich täglich aktualisieren. Und jede Zeitung erfindet ihr eigenes Interaktionskonzept. Da meinte ich schon, dass ich das eigentlich gar nicht verstehe, warum es keinen Magazine-Reader gibt, in dem die typischen Layout-Anforderungen eines Mags so realisierbar sind, die aber eben trotzdem auch so ein bisschen die Qualität eines E-Book-Readers mit sich bringen. Und eigentlich erfüllt sich mit diesem E-Books genau das.
Ich glaube, dass dir jeder Chefredakteur sofort erklären kann, warum sein Magazin nicht in der Lage ist, in so ein Format gepresst zu werden, weil es nämlich was ganz Besonderes ist. Und zwar jeder Einzelne. Da hatte ich diesen Ansatz...
Wenn er mir im gleichen Zug auch noch erklärt, warum sich sein Scheiß so schlecht verkauft, bitte.
Da hatte ich den Ansatz zu sagen, wir haben jetzt eine App für ein normales iPad und wir haben eine Newstand-App, dieses UI Newstand-Application-Blinks, da gibt es eine eigene Klasse für, die besondere Dinge kann.
Aber bei mir, ich glaube, ich habe jetzt den gleichen Bug, den du auch hattest. Das hier geht plötzlich gar nicht mehr, iBooks. Das ist jetzt iBooks-offen gerade.
Ich habe es nur überflogen, ich kann dir da jetzt keine Details zu sagen.
Das ist ein Teil von iOS 5.
Das ist eine eigene Art von App, die du da bastelst, die ein bisschen mehr kann im Prinzip. Und hast halt so Schnittstellen, um Dinge zu tun, die du halt nur als Newsstand-App machen kannst. Aber dafür wirst du dann im Newsstand gelistet. Das gibt's doch nicht.
Ja, aber dann bist du halt immer noch eine App. Ich finde ja, so ein Magazine, eine Zeitung kommt auch immer auf Papier. Und dieses iBooks ist für mich halt so Farbdruck.
Digital Papier.
Da kann man so diesen Inhalt von so einer Zeitung da so drauf machen. Ja, ich weiß, dann wollen sie noch ihre Kästchen haben und so weiter. Aber das ist halt auch Print. Ich möchte halt was haben, was, wenn überhaupt, wenn ich das überhaupt haben wollen würde, ich lese ja gar nicht so viele Magazine, aber mich stört dieses 1 zu 1-Übertragen von dieser ganzen Printwelt, weil das funktioniert halt einfach nicht so gut aus.
Ja, aber darum wär, glaub ich, auch iBooks nicht dafür gemacht. Weil das ist, was ich sehe, wenn man Magazine da rein kriegen will, die haben ja ihren Workflow, die haben irgendwo ihre Redaktionssysteme, wo sie ihre Texte und Artikel reinhacken und Fotos reinpacken. Und das muss dabei rauskommen. Da kann sich nicht jeden Tag jemand hinsetzen und mal so eine schöne Zeitschrift layouten. Sondern du brauchst eh Spezialsoftware. Und dann finde ich es eigentlich relativ konsequent zu sagen...
Was braucht man da Spezialsoftware? Alte Zeitungen werden mehr oder weniger mit derselben Software layoutet.
Nein.
Express oder...
Die haben so Redaktionssysteme. Dafür braucht man Redaktionssysteme.
Ja, aber von den Redaktionssystemen gibt es auch bestens eine Handvoll. Also das ist irgendwie...
Aber doch nicht zum Layout.
Doch, doch, auch zum Layout natürlich.
Redaktionssysteme.
Ja, aber das ist...
Wie viele können sich sowas leisten? Ein eigenes Layout-Programm, eigene Layout-Software.
Das ist nicht... Das ist ja nicht damit, damit es hübsch aussieht, sondern das ist ja damit du wirklich, damit du einen Text schon einsetzen kannst in die Software, während er noch geschrieben wird. Zum Beispiel. Weißt du, dass wenn dann der Redakteur fertig ist, da kommt der Artikel hin, der sitzt noch dran und tippt noch und sobald der da auf absenden klickt, ist der automatisch da drin und sowas. Das sind so die ganzen Flows, die du hast. Du musst ja bis zur letzten Sekunde seine Seite komplett umgestalten können. Und dann natürlich auch eben diese ganzen Sachen, wie ein Artikel, der da geschrieben wird, der muss ja in allen möglichen Medien auftauchen. Also Print und Webseite und was ist das für was? Also das ist nicht ganz trivial. Und ich glaube, wenn man diesen ganzen Prozess sowieso schon hat und die haben da, ich glaube, die wird von den Redaktionen sehr gehasst. Ich hab noch keine in Aktion gesehen. Aber so Spezialsoftware, die natürlich auch immer ganz krude zu bedienen ist. Aber wenn sie einen haben, dann bestören sie drauf.
Sehe ich, genauso wie du, hast du total recht. Ich sage ja auch nicht, iBooks ist schon das, was man jetzt nimmt, um das zu tun. Ich sage nur, das ist auf jeden Fall der richtige Weg. Gäbe ist jetzt sowas wie iMac Author. Und dann ist da eben auch so ein Publish und Subscribe oder weitergehende Bedürfnisse noch mit drin. Aber mehr oder weniger auf Basis des selben Formats. Was sich sicherlich auch weiterentwickeln wird. Ich finde einfach generell, dass so eine Zeitung für mich einfach Content ist. Und die sollte in einem Content-Format kommen. Und das kann flexibel sein und alles, aber es sollte nicht als eine App daherkommen. Sondern die App sollte eigentlich immer dieselbe sein. Weil das Blättern durch eine Zeitung funktioniert einfach in jedem Magazin gleich. Und das will ich jetzt auch nicht nur, weil ich jetzt in diesen Magazin gehe, diese Navigation habe und in dem will ich die haben. Auch Webseiten haben sich da auf Standards geeinigt.
Darf ich da mal eine steile These wagen?
Na immer.
Also Apple hat ja, was ich ja so komisch finde, sie haben ja dieses komische iBook-Author so unglaublich auf diesen Schulbuchmarkt reduziert. Etwas, was eigentlich nicht klar ist, wieso. Also im Prinzipie kann man damit ja alles lay outen, auch das Magazin, so wie du es gerne hättest. Und sie haben auch dieses iBook-Author ist ja auch so ein Lone Wolf Tool. Also du hast ja kein Gruppenanbindung in irgendwelcher Art und Weise. Was man jetzt unterstellen könnte ist, sie haben sich jetzt einen Markt rausgesucht, wo halt einer oder maximal zwei an einem Buch arbeiten, lange Zeit, und dann ist das irgendwann fertig. Da brauchst du keine gruppenfähige Software zu. Wenn du jetzt in den Printmarkt, also in diesen Magazinmarkt rein willst, brauchst du aber so eine Redaktionslösung. Und Apple stellt nie sowas auf einmal in einem Klotz hin. Sondern die testen immer so einen kleinen Nebenmarkt. Ist das überhaupt gängig? Können wir da die ersten Probleme mit ausbügeln und so weiter? Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie irgendwann halt auch den iBooks, Author, Magazine, Pro, sonst was machen.
Ja. Nee, das glaub ich nicht.
Jetzt mal abgesehen davon, das ist ja mit der Server-Software nicht so haben.
Es muss jetzt nicht gleich der Sprung sein von so Lone Wolf, kleines Schulbuch oder kleines hübsches Magazin auf komplettes Redaktionssystem. Aber dass sie natürlich den Anwendungsbereich von iBooks, Author sich erweitern. Das heißt ja auch nicht Textbooks, Author, das heißt iBook-Author. Das sind halt jetzt erst mal Textbooks, also Schulbücher, und könnten dann auch noch irgendwas anderes sein. Ich denke, wir werden eine ganze Menge Anwendungen sehen, wo das eben auch noch gebracht wird, wo man sich denkt, na ja, wenn man da jetzt noch das und das macht, ist super.
Also ich finde, dieses ganze Buch, also ich glaube, kein Nachrichten, kein News-Anbieter dieser Welt würde hingehen und sagen, ja, ich will da mein Ding im iBook-Store haben. Weil, wer will das nicht haben? Na die Anbieter, die Bildtagespiegel, die dann in entsprechenden Zeitschriften da sind.
Die Taz hat mal sowas versucht.
Die Taz hat es mal versucht. Weil jedes Mal ein Review-Prozess stand. Und dann hat Apple ja quasi darauf, macht doch was für Nachrichten, wie sollen wir da in die Zeitung reinkriegen, sind sie ja gerade mit diesem Newsstand-Format gekommen. Und ich glaube, das ist dafür auch das Richtige. Der Newsstand hat, was iBooks überhaupt nicht hat, die sind im App Store. Und der App Store ist das, was jeder Sau kennt. Und ich weiß nicht, wie erfolgreich dieser iBooks Store im Augenblick ist. Aber die Aussage, geh auf deinem iPhone, klick da das App Store-Icon, gib Bild ein und du kannst dein Bild lesen, oder was auch immer. Das ist was, was den Leuten leicht zu vermitteln ist. Dagegen, geh in den App Store, lad dir da was runter, das heißt iBooks, lad dir das runter, klick das Icon an, geh da aufs Dorf, such da nochmal nach Bild, lad dir das runter. Dann hast du kein Bild.
Seitdem sie diesen Newsstand eingeführt haben, also ich kenne da jetzt keine Statistiken, die ich selber gefälscht hätte, aber soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, hat das eben diesen ganzen Magazin-Apps einen Aufschwung gebracht. Was entscheidend ist, ist, dass Apple das promotet. Nicht so sehr, ob das jetzt der App Store ist oder irgendwas anderes. Wenn das da auf dem Homescreen ist und vorinstalliert ist und irgendwie sich meldet und sagt, hallo hier, nutze mich. Und vor allem haben sie diesen Newsstand schon. Ob die Leute da jetzt eine App runterladen oder ein Punkt iBook-File, was jeden Tag kommt, das ist denen egal. Hauptsache, die können lesen und das navigieren. Und wenn die Navigation immer dieselbe ist, umso besser. Ich könnte mir das sehr wohl vorstellen, dass man da auch iBooks reinlädt.
Okay, man könnte es besser integrieren, das stimmt.
Aber am Augenblick würde es nicht weiter auffallen, wenn der Newsstand auch gleichzeitig als iBook-Frontend, Abonnier-Frontend, arbeiten würde.
Ich glaube, die Stoßrichtung kam aus einer anderen Richtung, weil jedes Magazin hat sich seine eigene App sowieso zusammen basteln lassen. Weil sie der Meinung sind, dass nur sie das so können, wie der Leser das unbedingt braucht. Ich hab nicht so viele von denen gesehen, ich weiß nicht, wie schlimm oder gut die sind. Nur, ich kann mir vorstellen, es gab ja auch mal so eine Zeit, wo es auch noch keine richtigen Bücher auf dem iPhone gab und dann gab es halt so Firmen, die haben halt für jedes einzelne Buch eine App in den App Store getan. Und ich glaube, dass Apple einfach so dieses ganze Magazin-App-Thema mal so ein bisschen aus dem direkten Fokus des App Stores raus haben wollte, so nach der Art, ihr kriegt euer Newsstand und dann geht ihr bitte dahin und seid nicht mehr unter den normalen Apps, weil ihr seid ja keine Apps, ihr seid ja nur Bücher.
Ja, also ich denke, sie haben an all diesen Märkten ein großes Interesse. Also auf jeden Fall jetzt an diesem ganzen Schulbuchmarkt, weil das ist halt etwas, was auch vollkommen verharzt ist und wo sie einen riesen Unterschied machen. Gerade weil das iPad so stark ist jetzt schon in Schulen und in Education überhaupt, ist das einfach eine ganz logische Konsequenz und sie haben da auch, glaube ich, jetzt alles erdenkliche Sitzfleisch, um da abzuwarten und alle möglichen Kombinationen in der Richtung sind denkbar. Was ich mich jetzt noch gefragt habe, also worüber keiner so gesprochen hat, es kam ja iBooks 2, also die Lese ab in einer neuen Version, die dann halt auch das iBook Format kann, aber die kann ja auch nach wie vor ePub. In diesem iBooks Format gibt es eine ganze Menge Anleihen an ePub. Also das ist kein ePub, aber da gibt es hier und da Ähnlichkeiten. Also die Dinge, die sie eh so ähnlich machen wie ePub und wo das auch schon standardisiert ist, da verwenden sie eben. Es ist jetzt so ein bisschen so eine Mutmaßung, was ich rausgelesen habe.
Das ist kein offener Standard, oder?
ePub schon, aber iBooks nicht. Nein, nein, das wird es auch nicht werden. Das ist halt so was wie Keynote oder Pages. Das ist halt Apples Format.
Ja, schade eigentlich.
Was heißt schade? Es gibt halt keinen Standard, der das kann, was Apple da haben will.
Ja gut, aber das muss sie ja nicht daran hindern, da einen offenen Standard draus zu machen.
Ja, aber warum? Also wer würde so einen Standard akzeptieren von Apple? Da müssten sie halt in so ein Gremium gehen und diesen Standard halt über Jahre vorantreiben.
Ja, also sie haben das MPEG-4-Container-Format ja auch irgendwie aus QuickTime herausgelöst und als Standard irgendwie in das MPEG-Gremium reingeschmissen. Das wurde akzeptiert.
Ja, aber das ging in der anderen Reihenfolge.
Du meinst, das war schon ein Standard und dann kann man es auch stabilisieren?
QuickTime MOF gibt es seit 1900...
Ich will es gar nicht wissen.
1994, 92...
Ja, eine Weile.
Genau. Und MPEG-4-Konsortium hat sich das dann irgendwann in den Lid... Ich weiß gar nicht, wann war das?... irgendwann, viele viele Jahre später, als Basis des MP4-Container-Formats gewählt.
Gut, ich will mal ein anderes Beispiel bringen. Firewire zum Beispiel. Hat Apple entwickelt und haben sie als Standard offengelegt. Also ich meine, es ist nicht so, dass es nicht...
Also Hardware und Dateiformate... Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob sich das so gut vergleichen lässt.
Aber ich finde, ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie jetzt im nächsten Schritt sagen, okay, jetzt haben wir damit erst mal... Also dieses, wir preschen erst mal vor und dann sagen, guck mal, hier haben wir einen Standard und jetzt machen wir das mal vernünftig. Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie das machen. Wenn sie einen Vorteil für sich darin sehen.
Wo sollte da jetzt für sie der Vorteil sein? Ich meine, das sind Bücher fürs iPad. Diese Bücher sind genau für das iPad gemacht und nur für das iPad gemacht. Das ist das, was sie jetzt gerade im Augenblick... Es gibt überhaupt keine andere nennenswerte Plattform, auf die man jetzt groß targeten könnte. Und warum sollte Apple ein Interesse daran haben, was weiß ich, auch noch mit iBooks außer andere zu... Ich meine, sie haben ja diese Klausel in ihren Lizenzvereinbarungen. Wenn du diese Software benutzt, dann darfst du das, was dabei herauskommt, was ein bisschen schwammig formuliert ist, nicht verkaufen, es sei denn, du verkaufst es über ihren Store. Du darfst es kostenlos verbreiten. Du kannst es irgendwie zum Runterladen und überall und per E-Mail verschicken und alles. Also es ist irgendwie dein Fall, dein Content und alles. Nur verkaufen darfst du ihn halt nicht. Wenn du das tust, musst du es da machen, sonst brichst du eben diese Euler. Da haben natürlich auch gleich wieder alle Jehova geschrien und so. Wie sie sich denn das überhaupt so vorstellen können. Aber ich meine, gut, das ist jetzt der Deal. Ich meine, wenn dir das nicht passt, dann... Then don't do it. Also es wird ja keiner gezwungen, diese Bücher zu machen. Und wenn man das, wenn man halt das iPad targetten will, dann ist das halt der Weg.
Na gut, nachdem es kein offener Standard gibt, gibt es keinen anderen Reader. Insofern hat sich die Diskussion auch erst mal, würde ich sagen, erledigt.
Völlig erledigt, weil, genau, also...
Auf der anderen Seite ist iBooks Author ein kostenloses Tool. Also, da kann man jetzt auch schlecht sagen, irgendwie, ähm, da dürfen sie jetzt nicht... Weißt du, so nimmst oder nimmst nicht, aber es kostet halt nix.
Ja, selbst wenn es was kostet, ich meine, Keynote kostet ja auch Geld.
Ja, aber da gibt's nicht so eine Klausel.
Das stimmt.
Also, ich meine, ich könnte jetzt eine Keynote-Präsentation machen und sie einfach irgendwie über den Pay verticken.
Genau, das könntest du.
Geld ist bestimmt reich mit.
Aha, du kennst meine.
Das sind solche Keynote-Präsentationen, die da drin sind. Irgendwie, wie gesagt, könntest du ruhig noch alles ein bisschen... Ja, ihr redet doch die ganze Zeit.
Ja, also ich...
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie irgendwann noch mal einen Standard draus machen.
Also, warum ein Standard, glaube ich, für Apple überhaupt gar kein Thema ist, ist schlicht und ergreifend. Sie wollen da vorankommen. Sie wollen die nächste Version, die 2.0-Version machen, dann updaten sie ja iBooks Bang, sind sie schon wieder eine Version weiter. Also, die Welt schreit jetzt nicht unbedingt danach, dafür einen Standard zu haben. Ich meine, wenn die Welt der Meinung ist, man bräuchte für so etwas einen Standard, dann soll man das halt in Hip-Hop reinbauen. Und das ist sicherlich auch etwas, worüber jetzt viele Leute nachdenken. Ich persönlich finde das super. Also gerade, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Hip-Hop ihr so konsumiert habt schon so auf iPads.
Ja, einigermaßen, also gerade technische Sachen.
Ich fand aber, also der Zustand, also was ich jetzt mitbekommen habe, ist, viele Bücher sind wirklich schlecht formatiert. Also da gibt es einfach eine Menge Probleme. Da sind irgendwie Tabellen als Grafiken in schlechter Auflösung. Da sind Tabellen dann so, dass wenn du sie mit dem Print-Ergebnis vergleichst oder mit dem PDF vergleichst, sehen sie einfach mehr als mager aus.
Tabellen halte ich noch nicht. Was ich immer schlimm finde, sind Source-Code-Beispiele in technischen Büchern. Weil das ist ja eigentlich mit festen Umbrüchen auf eine feste Breite gelayoutet. Und wenn du den Zeichensatz größer machst, weil du willst die Augen schonen, dann hast du irgendwie eine komplette Wüste von Zeichen und kannst nichts mehr erkennen. Du musst den Zeichensatz wieder kleiner machen, bis diese ganzen Umbrüche weg sind, um dir den Source-Code anzugucken. Und wenn du dann weiter liest, musst du wieder größer machen, dass du wieder was siehst.
Und ich hatte den Fall, ich habe so ein Buch gekauft, ein Programmierbuch, und das kam dann so als Kindle-Version, also als.mobi, als EPUB und als PDF, sodass ich das auch mal ganz gut vergleichen konnte. Und dann hatten sie auch so ein Newline-Problem, und zwar, dass sie in den Terminal-Beispielen, so was du jetzt so eintippen sollst, also auch den Source-Code-Sachen, da fehlten dann die Newlines. Das war dann halt alles in einer Zeile, und brach dann wiederum um, und war einfach nur so ein Text-Blob.
Das ist natürlich die Frage, ob das jetzt wirklich übersehen haben, oder ob das ein Kompetitivitätsproblem war.
Ich hab ihnen das dann geschrieben, und hab gesagt, Leute, irgendwie, das ist ein Programmierbuch, was ihr mir da gerade verkauft habt, das kann wohl euer Ernst sein, dass irgendwie Zeilen, und ihr wisst, dass Zeilen beim Programmieren heilig sind. Dann haben sie mir zurückgeschrieben, ja, wir fixen das. Tatsächlich kam ein paar Tage später eine neue Version von dem Buch raus, was ich mir dann runtergeladen habe, und dann schaue ich mir das dann aber auch noch auf diesem Mobi an, weil das war in dem Moment die einzige Möglichkeit, mir das auch auf dem Mac anzuschauen, wenn ich nicht das PDF nehmen will, mit dieser Kindle ab. Und da waren dann die Newlines doppelt drin. Also, worauf ich hinausfälle, ist, diese ganzen Publishing-Changes, um wirklich High-Quality-Buchdokumente zu erzeugen, die auch wirklich eine angenehme Experience sind, dass du das wirklich Bock machst, das E-Book auch zu lesen und du nicht die ganze Zeit dir die PDF-Version herwünscht, weil sie besser layoutet ist, oder vielleicht sogar noch das Buch herbei wünscht, weil du da einfach schneller drin blättern kannst. Da hab ich einfach Mixed Results. Und an vielen Stellen liegt es auch einfach daran, dass E-Pub einfach noch nicht so viel kann. Weil das eben viele Sachen noch nicht macht. Jetzt frage ich mich halt, in iBooks gibt es halt E-Pub 3.0-Anleihen, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe. Kann iBooks 2 jetzt auch E-Pub 3.0-Bücher? Ja, aber E-Pub 3.0 soll eben auch so mehr HTML5-Features haben. Da geht ja eine Menge. Wir sehen das ja täglich auf Webseiten, wie sich das immer wieder verbessert mit der Interaktivität. Und wie Layer und Schnickes und Gedöns und so. Manches ist das iCandy. Das sind so Sachen, Dinge überlagern sich und so weiter. Du kannst Sachen hin und her schieben, du hast da irgendwie Dreck und Dropen. Das ist halt das, wie sich die ganzen Webseiten weiterentwickeln. Weil das jetzt einfach geht in HTML5. Und natürlich gibt es da auch eine ganze Menge Sachen. Ja gut, teilweise ging es auch schon vorher. Aber wir wissen alle, dass HTML5 die Sache quasi neu definiert. Und die Verbesserung der Webseiten in den letzten Jahren, die ist einfach enorm. Im Web hat sich einfach ganz lange Zeit nicht wirklich was getan. Da war man froh, dass man irgendwann mal keine Frames mehr sehen musste. Und dann wurde es hier ein bisschen bunter. Dann kam Flash und dann musste man nochmal 5-10 Jahre warten. Und jetzt ist da einfach Bewegung drin.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich will diesen ganzen Spielkram nicht in einem Buch haben.
Doch, ich will meine Tabellen sortieren können zum Beispiel. Ich will so eine Tabelle haben und ich will die sortieren können. Ich will da irgendwie draufklicken und sagen können, sortiere mir das jetzt nach der Spalte, nach der Spalte, nach der Spalte. Das ist ja auch etwas, was in diesem iBook drin ist. Auf einmal wird es auch ein Vorteil, dass das auf dem Computer ist. Und das ist nicht nur so ein Abbild des Buches.
Also man könnte da schon wirklich eine Menge machen, gerade auch bei technischen Dokumentationen, so irgendwie eine Tabelle, ein Code-Beispiel und dann ist ein erklärerter Text dazu, dass man das Code-Beispiel weiterhin sehen kann und den Text davon unabhängig scrollen kann. Nicht so irgendwie zehn Seiten später bezieht es sich noch auf ein Code-Sample, wo man dann beim Buch ja relativ entspannt mal beide Seiten offen halten kann, was einem iBook wirklich überhaupt nicht geht. Und da kann man echt noch einiges machen. Also ich glaube, bei diesen Büchern ist... Wobei, das ließe sich dann mit Hip-Hop wahrscheinlich sogar relativ leicht umsetzen. Also wenn man dann einmal die Elemente hat, das wäre bei iBooks nicht mehr so leicht.
Ja, aber dann halt auch so interaktive Sachen, dass man also auch wirklich solche Keynote-artigen, multimedialen, also interaktive Elemente drin hat und in dem Buch, um irgendwas gut zu visualisieren. Was weiß ich angenommen... Festplatten, Filesystem-Layout. Um sowas zu visualisieren, da brauchst du schon wirklich coole Grafiken. Und wie viel mehr könnte man tun mit so einer interaktiven Grafik, wo du dann immer wieder reinzoomen kannst und bestimmte Aspekte ein- und ausblenden kannst. Sachen, die du im Buch nicht machen kannst, wo du nur viel Platz verbrauchen kannst, um alle möglichen Iterationen da nebeneinander abzubilden, um den Überblick zu kriegen. Und so wird es natürlich sehr viel anschaulicher werden. Und wenn du dann eben gut mit Farbe arbeiten kannst und eben auch mit dieser Touch-Interaktion, da wird's einfach spaßig. Und das ist etwas, was eben E-Pub so derzeit noch nicht leistet. Aber ich glaube, iBooks weckt jetzt die Begehrlichkeiten in der Hinsicht. Zumindest wünsche ich mir das.
Also ich hab ein bisschen mit diesem iBook-Aussaß rumgespielt. Ich hab mir irgendwann mal in den Kopf gesetzt, mein Kochbuch zu schreiben. Das ist für mich total wirklich, weil ich kann nicht im Hauch kochen. Also ich kann Eier kochen, aber damit hat sie es auch schon.
Naja, das ist doch mal eine Aufgabe.
Und darum hab ich gedacht, mit iBooks könnte man jetzt ja eigentlich, da gibt's ja HTML-Widgets, die kann man auch in JavaScript programmieren. Okay, alles super. Und was ich nämlich für so ein Kochbuch gerne hätte, ist ein eingebauter Timer. Also natürlich nicht nur einer, sondern für jede. Also wenn da irgendwo steht, 10 Minuten kochen, dass man das 10 Minuten antippen kann und dass dann der Timer los tickt. Weil dann braucht man nicht irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Zusätzlichen. Das kann dieses Gerät perfekt. Und das wollte ich damit jetzt bauen. Und das ist erstmal, fängt es damit an, dass es leider nicht so ist, dass man einfach eine HTML-Datei importieren kann, sondern es muss tatsächlich eine Dashboard-Widget-Datei sein. Also das ist, äh, ne Dashcode heißt das. Also dieses Tool, mit dem man diese Dashboard-Widgets bauen kann, aber auch sonst ein paar HTML-Elemente, eben so ein Zeug. Das zweite ist, das wird leider nicht beim Start der Seite, also beim Öffnen der Seite, der Buchseite geladen, dieses HTML-Widget, sondern da ist erstmal leider nur ein Preview von zu sehen. Und erst on tap wird das tatsächlich geladen, das, äh, der HTML-Content und wird ausgeführt. Und ich hab dann nicht überprüft, ob ein Timer eventuell das tatsächlich überleben würde, aber ich hab dann mal vermutet, dass nicht und hab dann das kurze Experiment an der Stelle abgebrochen. Also, ähm, so richtig schön interaktiv geht das noch nicht. Aber ich freu mich schon darauf, wenn das erste Mal ein Buch kommt, was weiß ich was, mit Notenlernen, wo dann unten eine Klaviatur drin ist, wo die Noten auch mal an spielen kannst. Ich mein, das ist ja sagenhaft naheliegend. Und, ähm, dass da ein bisschen mehr kommt, das ist...
Ich hab vor diesem interaktiven Zeug immer so ein bisschen Angst, weil das wirkt so ein bisschen wie, äh, wir machen jetzt irgendwie einen Blu-ray-Disc und da ist interaktiv drin und dann kommt's da, dann ist dann wieder irgendein Java-Teil des Standards und, äh, hinterher funktioniert das alles überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ja, aber vielleicht, also ich meine, das ist doch gerade bei Schulbüchern macht das doch auch mal Sinn. Da hast du dann, ähm, das Ganze interaktiv zu machen. Da kannst du dich noch so richtig austoben.
Natürlich macht es Sinn, das interaktiv zu haben und wenn du so ein geschlossenes System hast, wie es Apple anbietet, dann kannst du das auch auf einer hohen Qualität machen. Nur wenn es ein allgemeiner Standard wird und der allgemeine Standard beinhaltet dann irgendeine Art von Programmiersprache, die wieder standardisiert werden muss, wo wieder Tools standardisiert werden muss, dann kommst du von Höchstchen aufs Stöchstchen und der Standard ist irgendwann nicht mehr benutzbar. Also ich finde, es ist ja eigentlich irgendwie ein... Das ist großartig, dass es HTML5 geschafft hat, zu einem Standard zu werden, der so viel kann und trotzdem ein Standard ist, der funktioniert. Also das hätte ja zu HTML4-Zeiten keiner mehr erwartet, dass es da irgendwo noch hingeht. Wollten ja alle schon xHTML machen. Ich glaube, ich will nicht mit interaktiven Büchern eine derart lange Entwicklung erleben, wie von HTML1 bis HTML5, sodass die interaktiven Bücher vielleicht in 15 Jahren ordentlich funktionieren.
Insofern ist es auch gut, dass dieses iBooks erstmal da ist, weil einer der Hauptgründe, warum HTML ja nicht vom Fleck gekommen ist, ist, dass man immer irgendwas spezifiziert hat und später haben sich dann die Leute mal vor diesen Standard gesetzt und versucht das zu implementieren und festgestellt, das geht alles nicht, ist nicht vollkommen beschrieben und so weiter. Bei HTML5 haben sie den Spieß umgedreht und haben gesagt, wir schreiben jetzt hier nichts rein, was nicht irgendwo auch schon läuft. Also erstmal implementieren und wenn sich das bewährt und wenn man auch so die allerersten Kinderkrankheiten auch schon mal erkannt und auch behoben hat, so dann spezifizieren wir das mal. Und sicherlich würde das auch dem IPAP-Standard ganz gut tun. Insofern ist es auch kein Fehler, wenn wir jetzt erstmal interessante Prototypen haben, auch wenn sie erstmal auf ganz anderen Dateiformaten basieren, aber eben den Bedarf nach Konzepten klar machen. In gewisser Hinsicht ist das auch das Gute, was ich über Flash sagen kann. Also so sehr man das hassen und verteufeln kann oder auch nicht, Flashs Vermächtnis ist, dass sie der Welt überhaupt erstmal einen Bedarf aufgezeigt haben, was an Interaktivität und Layout-Kontrolle und Event-Verständnis für Software überhaupt gefragt ist.
Was geht.
Genau, was geht und was auch wirklich sinnvoll ist.
Ja. Ja.
Aber das Web 2.0, das wird sowieso bald Geschichte sein.
Ich hab mir diese Präsentation für dieses iBooks ja angeguckt und fand das auch sehr, fand das, fand das, fand das, ich wollte mal gucken, wie machen die das so ohne Steve und so. Und in mir kam so, als ich das gesehen habe, die Frage auf, wieso ist Amazon in diesem ganzen Bildungsmarkt eigentlich nicht? Wieso sind die da nur so halbherzig drinnen? Tja, also ich weiß noch, die haben irgendwann mal diesen Kindle DX, der war, glaube ich, irgendwie mit größerem Display für, der war so für Schulbücher und so ein Zeug gedacht. Aber das klingt ja eigentlich nach nem tollen Bereich, wo man sich so schön drin austun kann. Ich meine, das ist billig, also so ein Kindle Bookreader, der wäre dafür wirklich perfekt. Die ganzen Schulbuchverlage, die könnten ihre feuchten DRM-Träume alle ausleben und könnten sicherstellen, dass das wirklich nur einmal und nicht kopiert wird und weiß ja teufel was. Und die Schüler, also die haben ja auch, Apple hat ja auch in dieser ganzen Präsentation, die haben ja auch sehr darauf so...
Du, kann man ganz einfach beantworten, sie haben kein iPad. Sie haben kein Multitouch-Gerät, was Farbe und Ton kann. Das haben sie jetzt das allererste Mal gerade zu Weihnachten mit dem Fire rausgebracht.
Aber jetzt Apple, die haben ja schon ein bisschen gespint, um zu sagen, für Schulbücher braucht man jetzt ein Multitouch-Display. Das ist ja so klassische Bücher oder einfach nur Leseliteratur oder Textbooks, davon reden sie ja die ganze Zeit, von Textbooks, also Lehrbücher. Die sind ja nun mal eher nicht so bunt und schwarz-weiß. Was?
Schulbücher?
Wann hast du das letzte Mal ein Schulbuch aufgemacht?
Naja, wann hast du das letzte Mal ein Schulbuch aufgemacht?
Mein Schulatlas war auch schon farbig und der war im 14. Jahrhundert.
Also es gibt Schulbücher, die nicht komplett aus Text bestehen. Das stimmt, aber so ein...
Es gibt keine Schulbücher mehr, die komplett aus Text bestehen.
Das ist ein wesentlichen Schon, was?
Nein, nein, das ist gedrucktes Multimedia, was die inzwischen machen. Vor allen Dingen sind die Teile so fett geworden, dass sich die Schüler alle irgendwie einen kapotten Rücken heben an dem Zeitpunkt.
Ja, aber ich bin noch vor 10 Jahren... Wann bin ich noch zur Schule gegangen? Vor 15 Jahren bin ich noch zur Schule gegangen. Wirklich?
Das merkt man dir gar nicht an.
Das merkt man mir gar nicht an. Und da war das im Wesentlichen so, dass wir keine irgendwelchen Bilderbücher hatten, sondern das waren Textbücher.
Deswegen sag ich, hast du dir heute mal Schulbücher angeguckt?
The times, they are changing, Max. Es geht voran. Und vor allem Schulbücher. Was spricht bitte dagegen, das mal in modern zu machen? Was hätte ich dafür getötet?
Nichts spricht dagegen, das in modern zu machen. Ich frag mich, warum ist Amazon nicht auf diesem Zug? Ach man, so billig ist das eigentlich. Ich frag mich wirklich, warum sie das nicht machen. Das war die Frage, die bei mir entstanden ist. Amazon hätte diesen Markt schon seit 3, 4 Jahren beerkannt können und hat es aus irgendeinem Grund nicht wirklich getan.
Diese e-Paper, diese e-Ink-Devices sind da einfach keine Alternative. Ich meine, die waren weder bunt, noch multimedial, noch interaktiv mit Touch und Tralala. Da konnten sie nach vorne oder zurückbleiben.
Jetzt sehen wir es gerade im Kreis.
Ja, aber das ist die Realität von diesen Teilen. Und die sind vor allem viel zu klein. Das iPad ist zwar jetzt auch nicht gerade den A0, aber es hat zumindest so eine kritische Größe, der Bildschirmgröße überschritten. Du kriegst da schon ordentlich Content drauf. Und der muss halt bloß dafür gemacht sein, aber du kannst das jetzt nicht beliebig kleinskalieren. Und so ein normaler Kindle, das taugt zum Lesen eines Groschenromans wunderbar. Oder auch eines richtigen Romans. Aber ein Schulbuch, was halt grafiken, farbige Grafiken, Illustrationen bieten muss, sollte.
Was habt ihr für Bücher gelesen in der Schule?
Also es geht jetzt nicht um die Romane im Deutschunterricht, ne?
Natürlich geht es auch um Romane im Deutschunterricht. Es geht um, was hat man im Geschichtsunterricht?
Ich rede von den Büchern, die man haben sollte. Ich bin sowieso ohne Schulbücher groß geworden, von daher bin ich da jetzt nicht der Vergleich. Aber wenn es gutes Unterrichtsmaterial gibt, dann sollte es natürlich so gut sein, wie es mir irgendwie geht.
Ja, das ist ja gar keine Frage.
Aber es ist ja auch müßig, darüber zu sinnieren, warum es Amazon nicht gemacht hat. Sie haben es nicht gemacht.
Übrigens zum Thema E-Reader. Ein Freund von mir, der hat sich jetzt ein Sony-Teil geschossen. Irgendwie so ein...
Selber Schuld.
Das ist irgendwie so mit Touch-Display. Irgendwie... Da läuft ein Android drauf. Ist ganz witzig. Man kann irgendwie diese Buch-Applikation beenden und dann kommt man zu einem normalen Android-Home-Screen.
Sicher, dass das von Sony ist? Nicht irgendein Nukeding?
Nee, nee, war es von Sony. Ich hatte es ja in der Hand. Das war ganz spannend, das Teil. Also hat mich jetzt mehr interessiert als so ein Kindle, muss ich mal ehrlich sagen, weil diese doch extrem geschlossene Kindle-Sache, naja.
Gibt es wenigstens Bücher. Also das ist ja schön am Kindle, es gibt Bücher dafür. Das gibt es ja für diese ganzen anderen Plattformen nicht.
Du kannst ja mit E-Pubs lesen.
Ja, und wo kriegt man die her? Also ich habe alle Versuche irgendwie, ich weiß noch, ich habe mir damals diese Datenfresser hier von, habe ich nie gelesen, habe ich nur gekauft, selbstverständlich hier von Frank Rieger und Konstanze Kurz, habe ich, weil das gab es weder im iBook Store noch bei Amazon. Und das habe ich mir dann in diversen Läden gesucht, das gab es immer in irgendwelchen DRM-verseuchten Formaten nur. Und dann habe ich mir das dann doch irgendwann da runtergeladen. Dann kriegt man so eine total kleine Datei und die musste man irgendwie hochladen in einer App. Und dann konnte die aufgrund dessen die Vollversion runterladen. Dann brauchte ich da so einen Blue Fire Reader. Das war wirklich... Dann hole ich mir doch lieber so ein Kindle. Da muss ich mir keine Gedanken um so was machen. Da ist das einfach drauf, das Buch.
Das muss doch auch wie so ein... E-Pub.
E-Pub ist echt.
Nee, E-Pub ist nicht so toll. Das ist halt der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner. Das ist halt der Standard.
Tim hat hier gerade so ein Ding aufgemacht. Ja, ich glaube, der ist es allerdings nicht der in Schwarz, sondern der in Rot war es.
Das sind doch geile Namen, oder? Ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, dass es jetzt... Sony ist auch echt dumm.
Dass es die gleiche Buchstabenfolge ist. Aber ich fand das Ding ja so eigentlich ganz schick.
Aber das sieht ein bisschen auch touch aus, das stimmt schon.
Jaja, der hat irgendwie ein Touch-Display. Das ist nicht übermäßig gut, aber man kann touchen. Wo blättet man da? Man kann da mit PDFs anzeigen. Das funktioniert erstaunlich gut. Also man kann tatsächlich auch reinzoomen und so. Auf diesem komischen E-Book-Display. Und ansonsten, naja... Das ist halt auch so ein Teil, was nix wiegt, was du halt einfach mal dabei haben kannst.
Naja. Naja. So, kommen wir vielleicht nochmal zurück zu diesem Education-Announcement, um die Sachen dann auch abzuschließen. Es gab ja noch einen zweiten Teil, den fand ich auch sehr interessant. Das ist diese Erweiterung des ITU-Programms, was sie ja schon längere Zeit haben, was bisher ja eigentlich nichts anderes war, als so ein gehaltenes Podcast-Verzeichnis von Vorträgen.
So kam es mir auch vorher.
Ja, das war es im Wesentlichen auch. Aber als solches hat es ja schon ganz gut funktioniert. Also es ist enorm viel Content drin. Ich finde es einfach interessant, dass man heutzutage eigentlich high-end studieren kann, ohne an der Uni danken zu müssen, oder? Ich meine, wenn ich mir das mal früher gehabt hätte...
Ich habe ja leider nicht die Zeit dafür.
Wahrscheinlich studiert man high-endiger, als wenn man an der Uni ist.
Du kriegst halt nicht den Titel, wenn er nicht geprüft wird. Aber wissen kannst du das dann halt alles?
Ja, vor allen Dingen kriegst du nicht den Prof, den die Uni gerade da hat, sondern kannst dir halt aus den Unterlagen, die da sind, die Besten raussuchen.
Also ich gucke mir das so alle Jahre mal an und bin jedes Mal überrascht, wie viel da eigentlich drin ist. Und dass man ja eigentlich mal müsste, wenn man mehr Zeit hätte. Hab dann aber natürlich nie die Zeit. Und ich hab mir da so einen iTunes-U-Kurs jetzt für iOS-Entwicklung mal angeguckt, einfach so die ersten Kapitel. Da drückt man auf Laden und dann hast du einen kompletten Studienkurs mit allen Videos, mit allen interaktiven Scheiß.
Sie haben diese App jetzt rausgebracht, das müssen wir auch mal kurz erläutern. Das erste Mal, bisher war es halt nur Podcast-Verzeichnis. Jetzt gibt es halt eine richtige App und die App kann eben auch mehr als nur Videos abspielen. Sie ist halt gedacht als interaktiver Kursbegleiter, wo du eben die kompletten Strukturen des Kurses hast, wo deine Aufgaben drin sind, wo du sie abhaken kannst, etc. Wo du gleich absladen kannst und sonstige Sachen. Das ist natürlich auch ein hervorragendes Medium, um die Leute an diesen iTunes Store zu binden. Aber es ist eben auch mal wieder ein interessanter Mehrwert. Also ich halte ja eine ganze Menge von solchen, wie soll man das nennen, Assisted Learning, Augmented University, wie auch immer. Also alles, was einen von diesem Scheiß, was einem eigentlich vom Lernen abhält, was einem das abnimmt, ist es irgendwie wert, getestet zu werden, mindestens. Und gerade so diese Termine, Übersicht, wo steht denn das jetzt? Da werden nach Aufgaben halt rumgemailt, dann kriegst du die Mail nicht. Und Mail ist ja schon ein Riesenvorsprung. Also ist auf jeden Fall alles sehr interessant.
Nun gut, also wer jetzt in IOS-Entwicklung einsteigen kann, der kann das mit diesem Kurs da kostenlos tun.
Genau.
Das finde ich schonmal echt spannend.
Gib mir mal den Link dazu.
Also als ich studiert habe, wurden Aufgaben noch nicht per E-Mail verschickt, sondern immer nur per kompirtem Zettel verteilt.
Aber heute wird das getan.
Jaja, ich hörte davon.
Kann man dafür überhaupt einen Link verschicken?
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Was, wofür? Für diesen Kurs.
Na, wenn es in diesem iTunes Store drin ist, dann gibt es da auch immer einen Link dazu. Ob du den auf deinem iPad generieren kannst, kann ich dir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sagen.
Gibt es denn was in iTunes?
Was genau?
Also diese ganzen Kurse, diese neuen Kurse, kann man sich dann überhaupt in iTunes angucken?
Es gibt doch iTunes U?
Ja, aber sind das nicht nur die alten? Nein, da ist es.
Stanford.
Ford 2011, das ist auch hochaktuell. Also sie haben iOS 5 und so, das ist wirklich...
Hau doch mal in den Chat, die wollen bestimmt alle...
Das war ich mal in den Chat hier.
Die wollen bestimmt alle iOS programmieren lernen.
Kann man echt machen.
Kommen wir zu unserem Scoop. Ja, wir haben mal wieder ein Vögelchen. Vögelchen sind ja eigentlich immer wieder das Schönste. So, im Leben. Und dieses Vögelchen hat uns ein paar interessante Informationen berichtet über den sagenumwobenen Apple Store in Berlin.
Das Idee ist noch der Leben durft. Oder der ist ja noch nicht so weit.
Also seit zwei Wochen oder so anderthalb Wochen ist ja dieser gemunkelte Ort am Kurfürstendamm mit so dem Apple-typischen schwarzen Bauverhau versehen, wo eigentlich...
Bauverhau.
Naja, halt so diese Schutz...
Also ich finde, man erkennt diese Apple-Baustellen schon allein da drin, dass sie sich die einzigen sind, die sich die Mühe machen, den Bauzaun zu designen und ihn schwarz zu machen. Sonst, wenn irgendwo gebaut wird, da kommen da ein paar Regips-Platten vor und fertig ist die Laube. Und die einzigen, die wirklich sich die Mühe machen, da das schwarz anzupinseln, ist Apple. Das hab ich sonst noch nirgendwo gesehen.
Vor allem, ist es nicht eigentlich so, dass nach Baurecht, wenn du jetzt was baust, dass du dann auch ein Bauschild aufstellen musst, wo drauf steht, was da gebaut wird?
In Deutschland ist das wohl so, ja.
Und was, wen hat Apple da im Schwitzkasten, dass sie das in Deutschland nicht tun müssen?
Interessante Frage.
Gute Frage.
Weil da steht nicht, hier baut Cupertino einen Apple Store oder so.
Meinst du nicht, dass da steht hier, dass die irgendwo baut werden?
Ich war da, ich hab das nicht gesehen.
Du bist extra hingefahren?
Ich war sowieso da in der Ecke, weil ich nämlich an einem Apple-Kurs teilgenommen habe, an einem Apple-Seminar.
In einem Apple-Seminar? Was ist da Apple-Seminiert?
Da wurde mir über Lien berichtet.
Ach, wie toll das ist.
Wie toll das ist.
Was ist denn Lien?
Das ist Scheiße, die sich da hinten abstürzt. Ja, glaubt mir immer keiner. Aber naja, ein paar kleine Details habe ich gelernt. Aber es war nicht so richtig alles neu. Aber kommen wir zurück zu dem Apple Store?
Aber stimmt, das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen. Die haben wirklich kein Baustellenschild. Also man hat ja öfter mal Baustellen, wo ein Baustellenschild ist, aber dann wird nicht gebaut.
Das gibt es auch.
Und Apple macht das andersrum. Die machen bauen, aber stellen kein Baustellenschild auf.
Tja, sie hätten ja mal...
Da hängt bestimmt irgendwo so ein kleiner Hinweis. Ich hab auch schon Baustellenschilder in der Größe eines DIN-A4-Blattes gesehen. Das kann sein, dass das zulässig ist und dass du an der richtigen Stelle gucken musst und dann siehst du diesen Zettel auch.
Vielleicht ist er auch ein bisschen weiter weg. Das ist so eine Schublade in Cupertino.
Also ich glaube, wenn es das irgendwo mal gegeben hätte, hier kommt gleich ein interessanter.
Die Berlin ist aber nicht Niedersachsen.
Vor der Durchführung genehmigungsbedürftiger oder nach § 69a genehmigungsfreier Baumaßnahmen hat der Bauherr auf dem Baugrundstück einen von der öffentlichen Verkehrsfläche auslesbares Schild dauerhaft anzubringen, dass die Bezeichnung der Bausmaßnahme und die Namen und Anschriften des Bauherren, der Entwurfsverfasserin oder des Entwurfsverfassers und der Unternehmer enthält. In Klammern Bauschild. Interessant. Ich hab ja auch schon mal ein Bauschild designt.
Ich meine, der Entwurfsverfasser und das Unternehmen, das Bauunternehmen sind wahrscheinlich beide nicht Apple, oder?
Es kann auf jeden Fall auch so ein A4-Shield sein.
Von der öffentlichen Verkehrsfläche aus lesbares Schild, den A4?
Das kann also ich meine ich hab so das Haus meiner Eltern hatte mal so ein Bauschild.
Der Bürgersteig ist aber auch eine öffentliche Verkehrsfläche, oder?
Das heißt nicht du darfst es nicht irgendwie nach hinten raushängen, sondern es muss ja, wenn du vorbeigehst, also musst du es jetzt nicht mit 180 auf der Autobahn noch lesen können im Vorbeifahren.
Sondern es ist so, es ist so ein kleines Schild oder ist so ein roter Kreis drauf? Also ich bin mir einfach sicher da ist nicht so ein Schild, weil wenn es dieses Schild da gäbe, dann wäre das schon seit dem Tag, wo es da aufgebaut wurde im Netz und wäre The News gewesen. Das gab es auch in München nicht, das gab es auch in Hamburg nicht, das gab es nirgendswo. Also da ist kein Schild, da ist halt alles schwarz. Die große Frage ist, was ist dahinter? Ja, so und hier bei Mowamaps, dem bestrecherchierenden Podcast überhaupt, werden wir jetzt mal spekulieren. Können wir euch so viel sagen? Erstens, das ist wirklich ein Apple Store. Der ist groß, fucking groß. Ich würde fast vermuten, also das ist auf jeden Fall der Größte in Deutschland.
Meinst du der Größte in Europa?
Nein.
Ich überleg gerade, ich kenne ja nicht alle Europäische, aber der Größte, den ich kenne und ich glaube, der auch noch der Größte ist, das ist der Region Store in London.
Oder in Paris?
Ist der in Paris größer?
Ich weiß nicht.
Da bin ich dann vorbeigelaufen und ich wusste nicht, dass der da ist, als ich da war.
Das ist echt peinlich.
Die Pauletten werden trauschiert. Das war echt peinlich. Fuck, den wollte ich unbedingt sehen. Aber der ist unter Garantie nicht so groß, weil der ist ja unterirdisch, dieser französische Store, und der ist jetzt nicht so mega groß. Da geht's so ein bisschen runter und da ist dann halt so ein bisschen verkauft. Aber dieser Apple Store in Berlin, der hat unten schon einen über zwei Etagen sich erstreckenden Bereich. Das ist der erste Apple Store, den ich überhaupt kenne, der Rolltreppen hat.
Rolltreppen? Das ist so unglaublich!
Ja, also der ist... Rolltreppen! Genau, also keine... Also ich weiß nicht, ob da auch noch Glastreppen reinkommen, aber der hat...
Wie ist das denn, wenn die dann einen beklatschen und man reinkommt, wird man die Rolltreppe hoch und dann klatschen die am Rand?
Im Chat ist man auch nicht ganz einig, was nun der Größe ist. Also wenn der Hamburger der Größe ist, der Hamburger ist das Pipifax im Vergleich zu dem, was sich hier in Berlin da abzeichnet, zumal das ja eben das alte Haus Wien ist, was auch mal ein Kino war und es gibt da auch noch oben einen Kinosaal. Wie groß? Also ich kenne das in Quadratmetern, kann ich dir das alles nicht sagen.
Ich kenne dieses Kino nicht, aber...
Ich war da auch nie drin.
Okay, das weiß ich auch nicht.
Das war auch lange Zeit was anderes. Kino Wien, oder? Nicht Kino Wien, das heißt Haus Wien.
Haus Wien.
Haben die da noch THX?
Das ist aber auch schon, glaube ich, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, das war ganz früher vor dem Krieg, war das halt ein Kino und ich weiß gar nicht, ob das nach dem Krieg überhaupt noch mal als Kino eröffnet wurde. Es gab einige Kinos am Kurfürstendamm, die lange Zeit auch betrieben wurden. Ein paar davon leben auch noch von den großen Kinos, aber meines Wissens gehörte das Gebäude nicht dazu und da war in letzter Zeit einfach nur noch so Trödel und Schund.
Also die Gerüchteküche meint irgendwas von viereinhalbtausend Quadratmeter wären es.
Viereinhalbtausend Quadratmeter. Und weiß die Gerüchteküche auch im Vergleich, was die anderen so haben? Auf jeden Fall sieht es so aus, als ob dieses Ding drei Etagen, wenn nicht sogar vier Etagen hat. Und da führen halt Rolltreppen durch. Oben dieser Kinosaal wird offensichtlich da auch das, wenn der Steve wüsste, genutzt. Und das wird einfach fett. Da können sie dann auch gleich zwei Genius Bars einbauen. Einen für die Öffentlichkeit und einen für mich.
Oh krass, also das hatte 850 Plätze das Kino. Also schon nicht klein.
Na passen, dann mal locker zehn MacBooks hin. Mit den typischen Ausstellungs-Diffensionen.
Und vielleicht sogar zwölf MacBooks erst.
Genau, und jetzt natürlich die große Frage, wann kommt er denn?
Der Apple Store.
Und wann kommt er? Ok, nehm ich mir mit Juli nix vor.
Das heißt, du wirst jetzt einen Kasten Mate auf Juli setzen.
Oh, da fällt mir noch ein Thema ein.
Und wir sitzen nicht dagegen.
Ich würde dich erinnern.
Bis Juli müssen wir noch warten.
Fuck.
Und das bei meinem grenzdebilen Zustand, in dem sich alle meine Systeme befinden. Das wird nicht schlimm. Also ich hab durch den iPhone-Restore hab ich ja den Zustand meines iPhones etwas verbessern können, aber...
Was hast du jetzt mit deinem iPhone gemacht?
Das hat sich am laufenden Meter rebooted. Also teilweise nicht nachvollziehbar, du bist einfach so mittendrin, startest irgendwas oder tust auch irgendwie nichts besonderes und auf einmal so bootet es oder es geht einfach nur aus und du musst es selber booten. Nachvollziehbar war es dann so, dass immer wenn ich gerade einen Anruf bekommen habe und es gerade am Ladekabel hing und ich dann während des Anrufes das Ladekabel rausgezogen habe, was hier im normalen Vorgang ist, der immer wieder stattfindet, weil das Ding liegt auf dem Tisch, lädt, dann ruft einer an, oh scheiße Verbindung, ich geh mal ans Fenster, rupft das Teil raus.
Normaler O2O.
Er geht zehn Sekunden weiter und merkt dann so, oh irgendwie tut sich hier nichts mehr, guckt das Ding an, aus. Oder bootet gerade, ja, hatte ich laufen. Dann hab ich irgendwann einen Restore gemacht, was ja so ein längerer Prozess ist, mit irgendwie alles wieder drauf spielen. Am Schluss ist ja zumindest erstmal alles, eigentlich sollte es eigentlich wieder so sein wie vorher. Seitdem ist es gefühlt etwas stabiler, aber ich hatte mindestens einen, so einen komischen Ausfall auch wieder.
Aber es klingt irgendwie nach Hardware-Defekt, oder?
Ja, ich meine, das ist, genau, also ich habe auch schon den Tipp bekommen, ich sollte doch mal einen Clean-Install machen, aber ich hoffe, das bleibt mir erspart.
Ach, also ich würde eher sagen, das klingt hier nach irgendwas, dass das dann...
Soll ja Wochen dauern.
Clean-Install, also ach, das ist doch...
Neues OS frisch drauf und dann alle Apps nochmal von Hand installieren und alle deine Settings von Hand...
Ach, das ist doch blödsinn, das ist doch wie mit diesem Homebutton rekalibrieren.
Scheiß.
Also ich mein, das ist doch... Ja, habt ihr das nie mitbekommen?
Ich hab davon gehört.
Da gibt's immer mal wieder so...
Ja, da muss man ja Homebutton, oder es ist ja bei so einem Apple-Gerät einfach ein Homebutton. Da ist das ja... Da ist ein Sensorik drin und das kann man rekalibrieren, indem man das drei Sekunden lang gedrückt hält. Die Gerüchte sind jetzt seitdem wieder ein bisschen ruhiger geworden, seitdem irgendwann mal, hey, ich hab den entsprechenden Code Reverse inginiert, der kann an und aus und das war's. Aber es gibt doch immer wieder so Gerüchte, auch dieses schöne mit dem man muss immer alle Hintergrundprogramme beenden, die da sind. Also da Doppel-Tap auf Home und dann alle Icons, die da sind, wegmachen, weil nur dann ist der Rampfreihe gegeben.
Es gibt Programme, die will man nicht im Hintergrund laufen haben und die macht man dann aus. Doch klar, es gibt schon Apps, die im Hintergrund weiterlaufen.
Mail zum Beispiel, Safari zum Beispiel.
Mail kannst du wahrscheinlich nicht beenden.
Podcast-Player zum Beispiel.
Na ja, aber auf nur Teile. Nein, nein, nicht wirklich.
GPS-Anwendungen.
Nein, GPS-Anwendungen, aber da kommen wir noch zu.
Die werden geweckt, wenn es soweit ist.
Ja, aber wenn du dich bewegst, dann änderst du deine Position und dann bekommt die App die Positions-Updates.
Na ja, die hört man die ganze Zeit regelmäßig. Naja, aber die läuft dann halt. Oder wenn du halt so einen Streaming-Service hast, Musik hörst oder wenn noch irgendwas runterlädt, zumindest für eine bestimmte Zeit. Also das ist halt so. Das geht nicht ewig, aber...
Ja, aber Streaming ist was eigenes. Ach, scheiße, ich kenn die eigentlich.
Ja, aber du hast gerade ein Hintergrund.
Wenn der Audio im Hintergrund abspielt, dann musst du halt laufen.
Nee, da laufen nur Teile weiter.
Ja, der Teil, der halt, da läuft halt was.
Aber da, also Maxi ist eine kleine App für Audio.
Ja, aber es läuft zum Teil genug im Hintergrund weiter, dass es so viel Akku frisst, dass du es halt nicht im Hintergrund laufen haben möchtest.
Ja, manchmal muss man halt auch mal Mail killen. Das hatte ich auch schon mal. Nee, mir passiert ja sowas immer. Was ich schon alles habe killen müssen.
Also dass ich gelegentlich mal eine App kille, die sich aufhängt, aber so dieses Standard-Ding von wegen, dass man, also es läuft auf dem iPhone im Hintergrund nichts. Das ist, das kann man einfach mal so...
iCloud muss ich auch mal irgendwie killen. Okay, iPhone-Probleme abgeschlossen. Wir waren beim Apple Store in Berlin, der im Juli kommt und wir waren jetzt dabei, dass iPhone ein bisschen instabil ist, weil ich halt vielleicht Apple Store-Bedarf habe. Ich fände es ganz gut, wenn ich nicht immer wieder nach Dresden oder nach Hamburg fahren muss.
Die haben auch so einen Postversand.
Ja, aber ich will mit Leuten reden. Ich will Service haben.
Ein iPhone hinschicken, neues Telefon zurückkriegen, ist Service genug?
Nein, ich will reden.
Tim ist der Podcaster, der will mit Leuten reden.
Willst du da reden?
Mein iPhone ist kaputt.
Ich will das Problem analysieren. Ich schicke denen doch nicht einfach mein iPhone.
Weil du dein neues kriegst und das Problem weggeschüttelt hast.
Ich kriege da nicht ein neues. Nein, ich habe da jetzt keinen Apple Care drauf. Das habe ich vergeigt, weil ich nämlich... Das erste, was ich hatte, war schon im Arsch, da habe ich ein neues bekommen und dann dachte ich irgendwie so in meinem Kopf, naja, jetzt habe ich ja noch mal ein Jahr Zeit, hatte ich aber nicht, so 90 Tage. Und dann ist irgendwie meine Apple Care-Frist abgelaufen und jetzt stehe ich ein bisschen doof da. Ich glaube irgendwie auch nicht... Also es sieht zwar nach Hardware aus, aber irgendwie glaube ich das auch nicht. Verstehst du, Hardware-Defekt ist schon noch mal irgendwie was anderes. Es sieht schon eher so nach komischer Software aus.
Also beim Kabel abziehen und dann rebootet sich das Telefon, das klingt für mich total nach Hardware. Das klingt nach irgendwas, Akku nicht mehr stark genug oder so was.
Ja, loot dann auch nicht, dann hast du ihn aber mal resettest, dann hat er wieder geladen. Also wenn ich dir das genauer erklären könnte, hätte ich das Problem wahrscheinlich auch schon gefunden. Naja, wo wir gerade bei wetten waren, Max.
Ich hab gesagt, ich hab dich schnell nochmal angehört. Ich auch.
Das war Mobile Max 41. Ich find das ja immer nett, wenn uns die Leute darauf hinweisen, was wir für wetten abgeschlossen haben. Aber so mit dem Photoshop auf dem iPad ist das irgendwie nix geworden. Zumindest nicht mit Histogrammen und Layern und so.
Das stimmt, damit ist leider nix geworden. Wobei darauf haben wir uns, das hat ja eher auch Denis vorgeschlagen.
Ja, ja, ja, jetzt kommen wir nicht so. Ich hab extra darauf gedrungen, dass man mal genau meint, was da drin sei und sowas gibt's halt nicht. Insofern fühl ich mich da bestätigt.
Du hast aber gesagt, dass es keine Profi-Software geben wird für das iPad. Das fand ich ja so, die das weit aus dem Fenster lehnen.
Bereich Bildbearbeitung. Ja, die gibt's auch nicht.
Das ist eigentlich aus dieser komischen Photoshop Fernsteuerung geworden. Die hatten doch so ein Ding, wo man irgendwie Teile des Bildes dann auf dem iPad sehen konnte oder so?
Ja, ne, die haben so eine Steuerungs-App fürs iPad. Die haben, also Adobe hat schon wirklich viel um Photoshop drumrum gemacht, aber tatsächlich kein Photoshop selbst. Die haben so eine, wie heißt das? Also es gibt natürlich Photoshop Elements fürs iPad. Aber das ist Elements oder Express heißt das, Express. Und dann haben sie dieses Adobe, was ist das? Genau, Adobe Enough for Photoshop. Das ist so, quasi kannst du deine Palette da drauf legen, als dein iPad als Palettenmonitor nutzen.
Ja klar.
Das ist definitiv Profi-Soft, das wird zugeben.
Ja, aber das ist kein eigenes Photoshop.
Das ist kein eigenes Photoshop, das muss ich zugeben. Das stimmt.
Kisse Mate. Noch besser, Kisse Flora Power. Ich sag ja auch von wo, ich schaff's nämlich schon seit Wochen nicht da mal hinzufahren.
Flora Power schmeckt genauso gut, es schmeckt exakt wie Lead Mate.
Ja.
Ich kann es nicht beurteilen, meine Lead Mate kam nie, die ich irgendwann mal...
Ich hab ja noch welche stehen, aber ich hab gerade keine Flora Power zum vergleichen.
Ich hab mich irgendwann mal im Februar letzten Jahres oder so bestellt.
Ich hab damals auch bestellt und die ist dann, hat eh nicht gedauert, aber dann plötzlich stand sie da und dann haben sie auch das Geld vom Umlandkonto abgebucht.
So, wollen wir jetzt mal endlich über Kalender reden?
Oh nein, ach komm!
Also ich würde, erst mal möchte ich gerne noch die Stelle hören, an der ich tatsächlich eingeschlagen hab zu diesem scheiß Photoshop-Ding. Weil das ist dummerweise die ganze Diskussion dann total untergegangen.
Wie du willst sie hören? Du spielst nicht die alte Sendung ein, wenn du das meinst.
Ja nee, aber du kannst mir danach vorspielen.
Danach?
Danach ist aber nicht jetzt, oder?
Genau, danach. Danach ist danach.
Ich sag dir hier iCloud, macht mich ja wirklich verrückt. Habt ihr da schon irgendwelche nennenswerten Erfahrungen?
Ja, ich nehme Google Mail.
Hast du für Mail?
Ja, und für Kalender. Aber das Thema hat man schon diverse, Mann.
Ich hab nur jetzt als Developer mal ein bisschen reingeguckt. Es ist ein bisschen merkwürdig, was die da sich da vorstellen.
Also wenn du benutzt hast?
Ja, also ich hab so, wie ich vorher mobile.me benutzt hab, benutze ich jetzt iCloud, also halt ohne Schlüsselbundsynchronisation.
Und hast du diesen Move gemacht? Du hast so gesagt, move mal. Und war danach dein mobile.me-Account geschlossen? Also war der dann weg oder kannst du den immer noch benutzen? Kannst du dich immer noch bei me.com anwählen? Also kopiert er nur die Daten rüber und dann hast du sie da? Oder ist danach der mobile.me-Account weg?
Ehrlich gesagt hab ich es danach nie wieder versucht, mich bei me.com anzumelden.
Da hast du noch das mobile.me-Control-Panel.
Ja, das hab ich noch.
Ja, und das ist noch angeschaltet, hast du da noch dein Account drin, ist ja noch aktiviert. Kannst du da noch auf Sync draufklickern? Zog da noch was?
Account-Statue. Ihr mobile.me-Account wurde auf iCloud aktualisiert, steht hier.
Und das heißt, da ist jetzt nichts mehr zu benutzen?
Mobile.me-Sync wurde deaktiviert, weil dein iCloud-Account aktiv ist.
iDisk?
Die iDisk könnte ich wohl noch verwenden, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Aber Keychain-Syncing nicht?
Nee, Keychain-Syncing glaube ich nicht. Naja, der ganze Sync-Tab ist nicht mehr da. Da steht nur noch mobile.me-Sync wurde deaktiviert, weil dein iCloud-Account aktiv ist. Verwenden Sie Mail, Kontakt und Kalender, um Sync zu verwalten. Und dann gibt es noch einen Button. Mail, Kontakte und Kalender.
Na, das ist der Grund, warum ich noch nicht umgezogen bin. Ich kann mobile.me gerade noch nicht vollständig verlassen. Weil? Weil ich mit jemandem einen Kalender teile über mobile.me, wo aber noch Snowlebat läuft. Da halt iCloud nicht unter Snowlebat geht.
Gar nicht?
Läuft der nicht mehr unter Line richtig?
Genau, das läuft doch nicht mal unter Line richtig.
Also das ist der Grund. So trotzdem hab ich jetzt auch das Problem, dass ich mit Leuten, die schon auf iCloud sind, auch Kalender sharen möchte. Und da dachte ich mir so, hm, weil als dieses Line so kam, das macht sich ja, also ich hab ja nie irgendwie gesagt, mach mal iCloud, aber es war ja dann auf einmal irgendwie da. Ich weiß nicht, wie euer Experience da war, aber wenn ihr einfach so, ja ich switch jetzt oder ich hab eh kein mobile.me gehabt und ich benutze das jetzt einfach, da hast du wahrscheinlich gar nicht so aufgefallen. Aber ich hab am Anfang tunlichst versucht, nicht irgendwo auf diese iCloud-Taste zu drücken und trotzdem war das irgendwann einfach so da. Und ich hatte auf verschiedenen Computern auch unterschiedliche Ergebnisse. Also während mir die iCloud-Control-Panels auf einem einen Computer immer nur vorgeschlagen haben, ja hier, move, move, move, ja, war bei dem anderen auf einmal irgendwie ein Account eingetragen und ach ja, und übrigens, ich hab jetzt mal deine Kontakte da auch schon mal hingesunken. Ich so bitte, was, wie, hallo? Ja, also der fing auf einmal an, einfach so diverse Dinge dann auch noch auf iCloud vorzuhalten. Da hab ich mir schon so, hm, gut, aber das könnte man auch nicht so richtig zurücknehmen. Also ich konnte zwar ausschalten, aber irgendwie war es da. Und dann hab ich irgendwie angefangen, die Sachen natürlich über iCloud zu benutzen, die eh nur über iCloud gehen, also natürlich so über die Apps und so. Und dann kamen jetzt so diese Kalender-Frage. Und dann saß ich da so neulich irgendwie so, hm, wie mach ich das jetzt? Jetzt würde ich gerne über iCloud da einen Kalender teilen. Mit einem anderen über iCloud. Es war eher so, es hätte jetzt auch Google gehen können. Zu Google komm ich auch gleich nochmal. Dann schalte ich das irgendwie ein. Und seitdem ist das irgendwie alles strange. Aber jetzt hab ich nämlich das Problem, ich kann zwar das tatsächlich machen, wobei wir im iCloud gleichzeitig benutzen. Ich hab da Kalender und da Kalender. Also das ist wirklich geil, ja? Und also in meinem iCal taucht sozusagen sowohl mein Mobile-Me-Account auf, als auch meine iCloud-Account.
Wie nennt man das? Thrill-Sieger, oder?
So, den kann ich da so eintragen. Da dachte ich, ja, gib mal dein iCloud ein und hier Apple-ID und so. Dann nehm ich meine Apple-ID, mit der ich das machen möchte. Und dann so, oh, das ist ja ein Kalender, super. Dann kann ich da auch schreiben. So, dann irgendwie Crickets, so, schlafen, aufwachen, wieder an den Computer kommen. Und dann ist da erstmal so wieder, so wie jetzt hier zum Beispiel gerade, wieder so ein kleines Warndreieck dran. So an diesem Account dran. Und dann sagt er, I can't log in to your iCloud account, because your password may be incorrect. May be incorrect. Ja, ist es jetzt korrekt oder ist es nicht korrekt? Und ich weiß, dass es irgendwie korrekt ist. Ich hab's mehrfach eingegeben. Ich gebe dieses Passwort am laufenden Meter ein. iTunes, I know my fucking password. Und ist ja auch richtig, weil sonst würde ich ja diese Kalender ja nicht sehen. Trotzdem meint er das. Und dann geh ich so in diese iCloud-Control-Panel, die gibt's ja dann auch noch, so mal so zu gucken, was da irgendwie so Sache ist. Kommt dann auch gleich hoch so, ja hier, incorrect password, dann gebe ich das irgendwie ein. So, dann nimmt er das irgendwie auch an und ist jetzt auch erst mal so weit zufrieden, meint aber dann mein Account wäre nicht verified. Account not verified. Check your email, blablabla, for instructions for verifying your account. Und dann kann ich hier sogar auf den Button draufklicken, Resend verification email. Ich habe noch nie eine Mail bekommen von Apple. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich jetzt auf diesen Scheiß-Button draufklickt habe. Ich kriege diese Scheiß-Verification-Mail nicht.
Was?
Erlaube. Ja, ich meine, hallo? Dann kam dieses Update, es ist wirklich, es ist mysteriös, ich fühle mich verfolgt. Dann kommt dieses Scheiß-Update für diese Time-Capsule, wo jetzt auch iCloud-Support ist, für dieses Back-to-my-Mac und so, trage ich da irgendwie ein, mache Update irgendwie, das Ding übernimmt das. Ich tue irgendwelche Dinge, gucke zwei Stunden später auf das noch offene Fenster da, wo diese Konfiguration steht, ist das wieder weg. Einfach so.
Ist das wieder weg?
Ja, dieser iCloud-Account, den ich da gerade in die Liste mit dazugenommen habe, zusätzlich zu dem Mobile-Mirr-Account, den er voll genommen hat.
Das ist einfach kein richtiges iCloud-Account. Irgendwas ist da, irgendwas hast du da, was teils ist.
Ich hab da Daten, meine Programme sinken, darüber...
Sicher, dass du da noch Daten hast?
Ja, ich schaue da drauf gerade.
Du hast irgendwie so was heilig.
Muss ich immer wieder mal das Passwort eingeben, damit dann überhaupt irgendwas sinkt. Ich sag dir, das ist einfach echt Teufels-Zock.
Also ich...
Und den Blick da zu sehen, das ist so, ich hab's wirklich gesehen. Das mein ich nicht übertrieben mit dem Teufel.
Ich bin irgendwann hochoffiziell umgezogen, mit einem flauen Gefühl im Magen.
Weil du wusstest, dass du Features vergisst.
Weil ich schon bei anderen Leuten gehört hatte, dass das dann auch schiefgehen kann. Obwohl, ich hatte so einen dieser Fälle, wo es halt mal gut geht, war kein Montagsumzug. Ja, Keychain-Syncing geht halt nicht mehr, aber ich benutze One Password, insofern ist es nicht so wild. Wenn ich irgendwo ein Passwort habe, dann muss ich es halt nochmal bei One Password rein tun und dann wird das halt über One Password gesynced.
Also wofür nutzt man das noch?
Die Keychain?
Also klar, da steht bestimmt eine Menge noch drinnen, aber so...
Naja...
Viele Programme legen ihren Kram in der Keychain ab.
Ja, Programme, also alles was kein Webbrowser ist und was halt Keys ablegt, legt das halt in der Keychain ab.
Ja, genau, aber das sind ja dann meist oder eigentlich immer Passwörter, die man sonst... Außer vielleicht Airport-Passwörter, die kann man ja vielleicht wirklich da über alles denken.
Zum Beispiel, alle deine Netze, wo du so reingehst, sind da drin.
Ja, aber dann hat man ja im Allgemeinen wahrscheinlich sowieso nur ein...
Ja, du hast ja auch sowas wie Tokens, Zugriffstokens und so ein Zeug.
Ja, mir ist das klar, dass jetzt... Ein Portal, einen mobilen Rechner.
Das ist ja egal. Wir gehen zum Prinzip, Max.
Wir gehen zum Prinzip. Du willst dich mit deinem Mac Pro auch ins Oberholz setzen.
Da will ich dabei sein.
Sagen Sie, ist hier noch etwas Platz für meinen 27-Zoll-Monitor?
Ist der Tisch auch stabil?
Super. Ich schau grad mal, was ich hier eigentlich so drin habe, außer den Web. Diese Keychain ist sowieso etwas verwirrend. Was es hier alles gibt, hier gibt es zum Beispiel auch Webform-Passwords, aber es gibt auch Internet-Passwörter und Network-Passwörter. FTP-Programme, Zugänger auf Server usw. So was landet da auch alles drin.
Ich habe da vielleicht ein SSH-Key. Komm!
Ich schreib auch gerne Passwörter in die Keychain, die ich gar nicht auf dem Rechner benutze, sondern auf anderen Rechnern, einfach um sie mir zu merken. Weil ich mir immer von der Keychain halt ein Passwort generieren lasse. Und dann benutze ich das Passwort irgendwo und dann trage ich den ganzen Scheiß in die Keychain ein. Und fertig.
Aber da findet sich auch ein Passwort.
Ja, das geht natürlich auch mit One Password. Aber das geht sich halt nicht überall rein.
Ja, aber es sind nicht mehr so viele Sachen, wo man noch ein Keychain hat, das meinte ich nur.
Ja klar, ich meine, im Prinzip ist es natürlich so, dass man das dann auch eigentlich alles in One Password haben will, weil das halt SYNKT, aber...
Irgendwie auch einen besseren Eindruck macht.
Als Keychain?
Zumindest was das SYNKT angeht, ja.
Naja, Keychain SYNKT gar nicht mehr. Ich meine, was für ein Eindruck soll es machen?
Disk Image, Passwörter, Zertifikate.
Stimmt, Disk Image. Sonst hör ich halt.
Ja, okay, ich hab ja aber sowieso...
Also man kann auch ohne, klar, aber es ist trotzdem nicht fein.
Und dann dieser ganze iOS-Developer und Mac App Store-Developer, Zertifikats- und Profils-Scheiß. Muss ich einfach mal so sagen. Das ist so ein krankes Zeug.
Und es wäre auch schöner, wenn noch mehr synchern würde, wenn z.B. auch mein iPhone diesen Keychain-Synch hätte, damit ich eben diese ganzen WLAN-Passwörter auch habe.
Naja, aber hat's doch eigentlich, oder nicht?
Also das wär mir jetzt neu, dass ich mit meinem Mac irgendwo hingehen kann. Also das iPhone macht keinen Keychain-Synch.
Stimmt. Die Keychain werden zwischen den iOS-Devices gesyncht?
Über MumbaiMe?
Nee. Ja, über iTunes.
Was? Nein. Nein, nein, nein.
Jetzt auch über iCloud. Oder was?
Nee. Nicht?
Das wüsste ich.
Also WLAN-Passwort muss ich immer auf beiden Geräten eingeben. Nerv total.
Kann sein.
Backup werden sie.
Aber nicht gesyncht.
Und ich glaube, im Augenblick gehen auch noch keinerlei irgendwie, dass man darf noch keine security-relevanten Daten über iCloud zynken. Also das haben sie zumindest.
Das haben sie so gesagt, ja. Machen wahrscheinlich trotzdem alle, aber.
Ja, aber dann ist es super.
Aber kommen wir wieder zu den Kalendern. Das sind einfach die wirklichen Probleme. Doch, meine schon. Für mich, also ernsthaft.
Macht bei dem Tim echt ein Problem.
Wieso? Für mich ist das wirklich eine ganz wichtige Anwendung, diese Kalendergeschichte. Und klar, jetzt so mit iCloud hat man Trouble, aber es gibt ja noch Google Kalender. Jetzt hat sich mit LINE ja die Integration von Google Kalender deutlich verbessert. Du kannst in diesem iCal, in allen Kalenderprogrammen auf Mac, jetzt relativ gut auch auf diese Google Kalender-Accounts zugreifen. Das heißt, du kriegst eben auch die anderen Kalender. Du hast nicht nur den einen, sondern auch die anderen. Musstest du bei Snowleopard dann noch für jeden einzelnen Kalender nochmal einen Account anlegen innerhalb von iCal. Ist das bei LINE jetzt so, dass du einen Google-Account anlegst und dass du dann diese Kalender in so einem extra Tab oder Delegates findest und dann anklicken kannst und dann hast du die auch.
Die Delegates konntest du doch nicht verändern. Oder kannst du die inzwischen verändern?
Wie meinst du das verändern? Also verändern in welcher Hinsicht?
Also du kannst irgendwie einen Delegate-Kalender, wenn du einen Google-Kalender hast, hast aber nur einen Delegate-Kalender, dann kannst du an dem nichts verändern. Irgendwie, weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht geht das inzwischen.
Ich hab das mal als Bug gefeilt irgendwann.
Es gibt Read-Only und Read-Freit. Das zeigt mich auch an, die Privileges hier.
Vielleicht haben sie das auch mal gefixt irgendwann. Aber mir ist es irgendwann aufgefallen, dass es nicht geht.
Mir ist immer ein bisschen unklar, wo es jetzt am Apple liegt. Dass der irgendwas nicht unterstützt, was Google kann oder umgekehrt. Das ist unklar. Ich will ja auch gar keinen schwarzen Peter in die Richtung schieben.
Bei Google weiß man ja auch nie so recht, was das alles soll. Diese Google-User-Interfaces sind ja alle so, dass ich sie nicht verstehe. Vielleicht liegt es auch an mir, aber ich verstehe Google-Mail nicht. Ich verstehe Google-Kalender nicht. Ich verstehe das alles nicht. Da sind immer so Features drin, wo ich immer so, was soll das Google? Was wollen die von mir? Also es ist irgendwie so, hm.
Naja, jetzt komme ich auf jeden Fall auf den Endspurt zum Thema Google. Also auf Line, Google-Kalender geht jetzt irgendwie. Man kann tatsächlich bei Google mehrere Kalender haben unter seinem Account und die in iCal alle sich selektiv einblenden lassen und auch read-freit machen. Soweit gut. Und dann fiel mir irgendwie auf, irgendwie sind die aber nicht auf meinem iPhone diese Kalender. Da dachte ich mir so, da musst du wahrscheinlich auch nochmal deinen Google-Account aktivieren.
Kann man auch?
Ja, dann geht man dann irgendwie in das Setting, wo man ja so die Mail-Accounts macht. Also das heißt ja hier auf dem iPhone, wie heißt das nochmal offiziell?
Mail-Kontakte und Kalender, glaube ich.
Genau, und Mail-Kontakte, Kalender, was halt eine sehr merkwürdige Klassifizierung schon immer war. Unter LINE gibt es ja jetzt dieses neue Accounts-Control-Panel, wo so alle deine Accounts systemweit irgendwie vorgehalten werden und auch was du da in iCal eingibst landet letztlich da. Was an sich schon mal eine ganz gute Idee ist, wie ich finde, dass so Accounts bei irgendwelchen Diensten auch zentral gespeichert werden. Hätte ich bloß mehr Konsequenz erwartet, wo sind irgendwie meine Twitter und sonstigen Accounts, dass man das einfach zentral, ja wieso? Wenn dann andere Programme darauf zugreifen wollen, musst du nur noch sagen, du darfst darauf zugreifen. So ähnlich wie das jetzt auch mit der Twitter-Integration bei iOS ist. Warum sollst du immer wieder alles nochmal in jedem einzelnen Programm eingeben, wenn du das auch zentral verwalten kannst? Das macht total Sinn.
Vielleicht sind diese Kalender und so weiter, das sind halt so die Sachen, die wirklich viele Programme benutzen, während Twitter, gut, hat sich jetzt auch dazu verbreitet, aber ich glaube, die Leute, die irgendwie drei verschiedene Twitter-Clients auf einmal verwenden, sind ja doch dann eher in der Unterzahl.
Nee, im Augenblick kriegt er einfach alles nur einen Account, was Systemintegration hat. Also Twitter halt und halt Kalender. Und Kalender, Kontakte und Mail, das ist ja im Allgemeinen auch derselbe Account alles.
Ja, also es heißt unter LINE sogar genauso, Mail, Kontakte und Kalenders. Genau. Das heißt im Prinzip ist das jetzt hier schon derselbe Ansatz. Was hab ich denn hier drin? Ich hab hier iCloud drin, ich hab hier Mobile Me. Ich hab hier alle meine Google-Accounts drin. Ich hab alle meine Mail-Accounts da drin. Ich hab meine iChat-Jobber-Accounts da drin.
Ich hab sogar meinen Facebook-Chat hier drin.
Ich hab sogar einen AOL-Chat drin.
Ja, das macht auch eigentlich total Sinn. Also ich find den Ansatz ganz gut. Wie auch immer. Jetzt hab ich meinen Google da drin und siehe da. Ich kann auch da auf Kalender gehen. Aber ich sehe nur den Default-Kalender.
Wie hast du den Google-Kalender eingerichtet?
Wie meinst du das, wie ich den eingerichtet habe? Auf Google-Seite?
Nee, wenn man den auf dem iPhone. Den muss man als, also ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch so ist. Früher musste man den als Exchange-Server einrichten.
Genau, das ist nämlich ein Active-Sync.
Genau, das hast du gemacht.
Das kann man hier gar nicht weiter definieren, sondern du holst einfach den Google-Account an und dann ist das so.
Dann ist es ein Active-Sync mittlerweile. Früher war es das nicht. Früher war es dann iMap-Account. Und dann konntest du gar keinen Kalender drüber.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo du den löschen möchtest, dann kommt so ein, bist du dir sicher, Dialog und da steht, möchten sie wirklich fortfahren. Gut, dann sag ich dir jetzt wieder, dann fahren sämtliche Exchange-Active-Sync-Kalender-Daten werden von ihrem iPhone entfernt.
Dann sag ich dir jetzt wieder, wie du in deinem anderen Kalender rankommst.
Man geht auf diese komische Google-Seite www.google.com/iphoneselecttralala Kalender slash iphone select.
Die URL ist m.google.com/sync.
Na, die aktuelle Google FAQ sagt was anderes.
Das ist die, die ich auswendig weiß. Kann man sich auch gut merken, wenn ich jedes Mal, wenn einer von meinen Freunden wieder mal sein iPhone aus dem Fenster geworfen hat und ein neues hat und danach wieder seinen ganzen Daten einrichten muss. Das geht aber auch wirklich nur vom iPhone aus. Dann kommt man auf eine Seite, auf der steht, diese Seite ist in ihrer Sprache leider nicht verfügbar. Und dann sagt man...
Nee, sprach ich nicht. Da kommen gerade, sehr interessant, ich kriege gerade eine Seite von Google, wo vier iPhones und zwei iPads gelistet sind.
Na deine Geräte, was du so im Laufe der Zeit hattest.
Ja, und weiss ich jetzt welches dieser...
Also bei mir kommt da Gerät nicht unterstützt und da steht, Google Sync wird auf ihrem Gerät nicht unterstützt. Unter Google finden sie mehr dazu und unten ist ein Link Sprache ändern. Wenn ich da auf Sprache ändern klicke, dann kann ich die Sprache wählen, dann sage ich da English US, dann leitet mich wieder auf dieselbe Seite, aber diesmal geht's, also man muss nur die Sprache ändern. Das hat Google seit irgendwie zweieinhalb Jahren nicht richtig hingekriegt.
Okay, ich komme jetzt tatsächlich auf ein Kalender-Setting, wo ich jetzt nochmal diese Kalender angebe, weil es gab nämlich, ich habe da schon nach gesucht und es gibt auch noch die Seite google.com/kalender/iphone Select und auch da hat er mir angeboten, alle Kalender sozusagen frei zu schalten für mein iPhone. Warum auch immer er das überhaupt trennt. Jetzt mache ich das nochmal mit diesem Interface, was du mir jetzt gerade gesagt hast, was was anderes ist. Das ist wirklich gnadenlos.
Ja, das ist furchtbar.
Ich rufe bald PIK Google aus.
Das ist lange vorbei.
Wann müsste diese Änderung sichtbar sein und durch was hervorgerufen?
Das dauert so vier, fünf Minuten, dann ist es da.
Von alleine oder muss ich jetzt die Kalender abstarten?
Du hackst die Kalender ab, sagst dann Speichern und danach kommen die von alleine. Das dauert ein bisschen und dann sind sie da.
Okay, dann leg ich das jetzt...
Was sind sie? Max?
Habe ich doch noch...
Jetzt hast du dir schon mal die erste Hälfte von der Mathe. Du hast ja schon wieder raus.
Ich sehe schon, das ist nicht die Kulturwert-Markt, das ist die Kulturwert-Mate, mit der hier bezahlt wird.
Der Grund, warum sie das so freigeschaltet haben, mit dieser Begrenzung, ist, die haben ja dafür Exchange lizenziert von Microsoft. Und hatten eine Begrenzung drinnen, dass sie maximal fünf Kalender synchronisieren dürfen. Darum musste die halt nochmal separat auswählen, welche Kalender du haben möchtest. Darum können sie nicht einfach alle reinpacken. Mittlerweile wurde das erhöht auf 25 Kalender.
Aber warum schalten sie mir nicht einfach alle frei?
Mittlerweile könnten sie das machen.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich müssen sie insgesamt wie viele tatsächlich geshared werden.
Vielleicht dafür bezahlen, das kann natürlich sein. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Vielleicht auch, weil es mit anderen Geräten nicht geht. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Aber auf jeden Fall dieses m.google.com/sync, dann Sprache wechseln, dann auf Englisch umschalten und dann geht's plötzlich. Das ist so der Weg, den kann ich auswendig.
Ja, dann darfst du die nächste Zahl fürs Jeopardy aufrufen. Das hättest du gern. Das war jetzt Kalender für 100.
War das nicht Google für 300?
Oh Gott, ich hab eine Kalenderfrage. Was muss man tun, um seine E-Mail-Signatur zu ändern? Ich hab neulich auch vor Google Mail gesessen. Die haben jetzt dieses neue Interface und hab mich wirklich von ganzen Herzen darüber aufgeregt. Warte mal, ich wechsle mal kurz den Account, obwohl es auch wurscht, ob es über den Account ist. Also ich hab hier meinen Google-Account und jetzt möchte ich gern auf meine Kontakt zugreifen. Auf meinem Bildschirm, den ich gerade euch vorhabe.
Was heißt das, du hast deinen Google-Account?
Im Browserfenster offen, genau. Was muss ich tun, um an meine Kontakte zu kommen? Richtig auf Mail klicken. Man muss hier oben auf Mail klicken und dann kommt so ein kleines Menü, wo man dann auswählen kann Kontakte. Und ich hab wirklich Stunden gesucht. Früher war das irgendwie mal, da stand da einfach Contacts. Und jetzt ist hier dieses kleine Menü, wenn man auf Mail klickt. Aber was sie sich dabei gedacht haben, die Kontakte unter Mail zu verstecken, ich versteh's nicht. Das ist so wie bei Windows dieser Start-Button zum Beenden. Aber, wenn man einmal weiß, dann geht's.
Google sieht sich aus.
Andere setzen das BWW aus, du nur Google, das ist ja schon mal, dann ist es ja schon mal relativ entspannt. Kommen gerade die ersten Dankesrufe per Twitter rein.
Das hat aber ganz schön lange gedauert.
Angeblich soll man keine Kalender-Items löschen können vom iPhone aus, das werde ich jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Vom iPhone aus?
Ja, also da, wo ich jetzt gerade was freigeschaltet habe, das werde ich jetzt mal ausprobieren. Jetzt werde ich mal gucken, wie lange das hier auch braucht, bis das hier auf mein Telefon draufsankt. Sankt.
Telefon.
Da kann ich ja noch mal an der Stelle auf was hinweisen, wenn sie mal öfters mal Apple Dokumentationen lesen wollt. Da gibt es ja dieses in Xcode, dieses Indizieren, was irgendwie auf einem Apple IIe Emulator läuft, der im Hintergrund, keine Ahnung. Und da gab es jetzt auf Heise, gab es von Ole, ich weiß nicht wer Ole ist, aber alle, achja, Ole. Nee, Ole Zorn.
Den kenne ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Gut, erst, als ich gesagt habe, Ole, ja klar, also darum tue ich jetzt auch immer so, als ob ich den kenne, der hat auch sonst ein paar Hübsches. Der hat die iPad-App Docsets geschrieben, kann man sich auf seinem Git-Repository runterladen und einfach basteln, bauen. Sieht sehr schön aus, ich hab mir das mal installiert auf meinem kleinen iPad.
Wie heißt das, wie heißt ihr das, Entschuldigung?
Docsets, Docsets mit mehr. DoCsets, genau.
Und ist das nicht im Upstore?
Wie gesagt, kann man sich per GitHub installieren. Wenn man Apple Dokumentationen liest, ist ja sowieso...
Wenn du Entwickler bist, dann hast du sowieso.
Dann ist es ja auch okay. Dann baut man sich das mal rasch zusammen und geht auch ganz schmerzlos. Die Suche ist schneller als auf dem Mac. Das ist echt krass. Und dann hat hier Herr Media-Atelier, der hier dieses Alarms auf dem Mac, oben dieses Kalenderprogramm, wo man Alarme rein spontan rascheln kann, der hat dann auch ausgebuddelt, er hat es nicht geschrieben, ich glaube darauf liegt der Wert, dass er es nicht geschrieben hat, eine App namens Dash, das ist jetzt für Mac, die gibt es im Mac App Store. Das ist so ziemlich das hässlichste Interface, das ich jemals gesehen habe. Und vor allen Dingen, dass wirklich, hier kann man das Fenster nicht bewegen. Ach fuck, jetzt ist es hier so, das hab ich vorhin auf einem großen Bildschirm aufgehabt und jetzt kriegt er natürlich nicht mit.
Wo ist der Pieps-Button?
Wir sind ja hier nicht in Amerika. Ach, jetzt ist er tatsächlich, ah siehst du, guck dir dieses Fenster an. Hier oben, also oben rechts in der Ecke von dem Fenster ist ein Kreis, der ist einfach nur groß. Ja stellt euch einen Kreis vor.
Wie heißt das Produkt, über das du gerade rankest?
Dash D-A-S-H.
Einfach nur Dash?
Einfach nur Dash.
Ich kann gleich einen App Store-Link dazu packen.
Das ist ja irgendwie ein Produkt, das man gut googeln kann, würde ich sagen.
Aber es ist schnell. Es ist schneller als diese Apple-Doku. Man kann es mit einem Shortcut einblenden. Ich habe das jetzt auf Apfel-Alt-Lehrtaste gelegt. Dann kann man direkt anfangen, loszutippen. UI, Table View, Controller, um nochmal was nachzuschlagen, was man da zum 120. Mal vergessen hat.
Ich muss mal sagen, so schlecht ist die Apple-Doku, die jetzt bei Xcode eingebaut ist, auch nicht.
Die ist nicht schlecht, die ist einfach unglaublich langsam. Nein, nein, Dash.
Man muss mal sagen, das ist schon... Man kommt auch echt durcheinander, in welchem fucking Store man gerade gucken soll. Mit dieser Katze.
Mit dieser Katze, ja genau.
Snippet Manager.
Das Interface ist schon sehr...
Jemand fragt dir hier gerade noch, ob es nur funktioniert, wenn man Google als Exchange einrichtet. Nein, Tim hat es ja gerade erzählt. Tim hat es ja nicht als Exchange eingerichtet und hat es trotzdem.
Wobei ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr weiß, wie ich das seinerzeit mal eingerichtet habe.
Also ich richte die immer als Exchange ein.
Genau, genau.
Genau, da kann man also schön... Ja, ja, der hat einen eigenen Google-Menüpunkt und das ist halt das, was immer alle machen. Und dann haben sie nur einen IMAP-Account und wundern sich, warum sie keinen... können dafür aber Notizen, das ist ja immer das Lustige, weil Exchange kann keine Notizen.
Ich hab's als Exchange-Account angenommen.
Ah, okay, gut, dann muss man es als Exchange-Account anlegen. Genau, das ist auch wichtig. Es gibt eine Seite bei Google, wo steht, wie man das als Exchange-Account anlegt direkt.
Ah, und sonst gibt's noch Google Mail, verstehe.
Aber dieses kleine...
Die machen es einem auch nicht einfach. Ich weiß bloß immer nicht, wer es einem jetzt grad nicht einfach macht.
Ja, ich glaube, da in dem Fall ist tatsächlich mal Apple der Schuld, weil die wahrscheinlich einfach nicht ihre entsprechenden Dictionaries aktualisieren, wo drin steht, dass das ein Exchange-Account sein soll. Das ist jetzt auch meine Vermutung.
Also irgendjemand meinte, man könnte dann diese Google-Kalender nicht auf dem Mac löschen. Das kann ich nicht nur nicht bestätigen, ich kann sie nur bestätigen, dass das Gegenteil...
Du kannst den Kalender nicht löschen oder die Einträge?
Also funktioniert alles. Ich kann das Problem nicht nachvollziehen.
Nee, also ich bin mit Google-Kalender eigentlich soweit ganz glücklich. Und bisher musste ich noch nie ein Update machen, wo dann plötzlich meine alten Kontakte weg waren. Das funktioniert schon alles, ganz dürfte.
Wo wir gerade schon bei iPhone-Apps gelandet sind, gibt es hier noch ein paar Neuigkeiten aus dem iPhone-Podcast-Appfeld. Ich hatte ja gesagt, dass ich mir mal diese ganzen Podcasting-Apps genauer anschauen will. Das habe ich auch getan. Wozu es noch nicht gekommen ist, ist mal wirklich so eine dicke, fette Matrix aufzuzeichnen, wo ich so die Key-Features miteinander vergleiche, so dass ich mal so schön runterbeten könnte, was jetzt so welche Vorteile hat wie Huckel, das seinerzeit mal so schön mit diesen Cloud-Services gemacht hat. Sprich, ich müsste mir das jetzt hier gerade auch noch mal interaktiv erarbeiten, aber ich habe eine ganze Menge Zeit mit Instacast verbracht und vor allem bin ich da auch gerade am Beta-Testen der kommenden Versionen, die jetzt wohl gerade auch in den App Store eingestellt wurde. Du auch, oder Max?
Ja.
Ist sie schon? Die ist noch gar nicht da. Also ich sehe sie ja noch nicht.
Nein, sie ist noch nicht draußen, weil das dauert halt jetzt so lange wie auch immer, wie lange das auch immer dauern mag, bei Apple. Ich weiß nicht, was so derzeit so der Average ist. So ein paar Tage wird es schon dauern.
Geht manchmal auch extrem schnell.
Manchmal geht es schnell, manchmal geht es nicht so schnell.
Also das allererste Review dauert immer viel, viel länger, als wenn man dann ein Update pusht. Also das ist ganz normal. Das hängt auch immer ein bisschen davon ab, was man für einen Sachbearbeiter bekommt und wie genau er sich das anguckt.
Wie beim Finanzamt.
Doch, total. Ich hab das bei meiner App auch irgendwann mal gemerkt. Da hab ich wohl einen neuen Sachbearbeiter gekriegt. Und dann hat er ein bisschen anders geklickt als alle vor ihm. Und dann hat er einen Crash-Bug gefunden, der schon seit Ewigkeiten in der App geschlummert hat. Das hat halt nur jemand gemacht. Vorher die so zu benutzen.
Ja, ja, ist immer gut unabhängige Tester zu haben.
Im Idealfall schon vorher.
Da hab ich den Bug gefixt, das wieder reingetan, hab dann dazu geschrieben, ja, ja, hier, Crash-Bug gefixt, den die Reviewer gefunden haben. Und dann haben sie es abgelehnt, so, ja, nee, das darf man nicht schreiben. Also man darf den Review-Prozess als solchen nicht in der Beschreibung der App oder des Updates verwenden.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, neben so ein paar kleinen Detailverbesserungen gibt es ein extrem cooles neues Feature in Instacast. Ich bin jetzt so mit der konkreten Umsetzung noch nicht so hundertprozentig glücklich, aber ich bin auf jeden Fall, findest du schon mal sehr cool, dass es drin ist. Und zwar ist Instacast jetzt so der erste Podcast-Client, der Flatter-Support mit drin hat. Flatter hat ja vor kurzem endlich mal dokumentiert, wie man einen, also wie man quasi einen Flatter-Button maschinenlesbar in Feats packt. Und ich hab die da mal so ein bisschen hingetrieben, muss ich auch dazu sagen.
Hingetreten.
Ich wollte das mal wissen, wie denn das so ist und so und dann haben sie so eine Spezifikation aus dem Hut gezaubert und irgendwann war sie dann auch dokumentiert. Und jetzt ist das eben die erste App, von der ich weiß, wobei ich auch gehört habe, gelesen habe, dass wohl hier auch Bits und so in seiner Spezial-App das auch einbaut. Also das ist jetzt so etwas, was kommt. Interessanterweise braucht es noch nicht mal des spezifischen neuen Link-Features, was da vorgeschlagen wird, auch wenn das die beste Lösung ist, sondern Instacast macht auch so ein Scraping, das heißt, es funktioniert auch jetzt schon mit allen Feeds, wo Flatter in der Beschreibung mit drin ist und beim RSS nicht rausgefallen ist. Aber es ist so mit HTML Scraping und so weiter wissen wir alle, das ist alles nicht so das Beste. Wenn es geht, geht es. Allerdings für alle Leute, die jetzt Podcasting mit WordPress machen, gleich mal der Tipp hinterher. Da kommt auch recht bald, hoffe ich, das ist auch schon in Arbeit, ein Update für dieses Flatter-Plugin und da wird das dann auch mit drin sein. Und dann ist das Ökosystem an der Stelle das erste Mal geschlossen. Das heißt, man kann über seinen Feed quasi maschinenlesbar diese Flatter-Informationen werden einfach so mit durchgereicht, ganz automatisch und ein Podcast-Client kann das halt machen. Und bei Instacast ist es so, dass du halt entweder sagen kannst, ok, das flattere ich jetzt und zwar sowohl per Episode als auch per Podcast. Ganz nur einmal, weil diese Subscription geht derzeit noch nicht. Also das geht flatterseitig noch nicht. Aber er hat halt auch so einen Feature eingebaut, wo du sagen kannst, flatter einfach alles, was ich höre, was flatterbar ist. Das ist einfach sozusagen in dem Moment, wo du die Episode hörst.
Ach, das ist ja mal schön.
Und das Flatterbar wird's halt einfach gleich geflattert, so was du da gar nicht groß drüber nachdenken musst, das klickt sich quasi von alleine.
Ja, so will man's haben. Ich meine, natürlich flattert man eigentlich alles, was man hört. Weil man hat's ja gehört, dann kann man's auch flattern.
Das ist so ein Auto-Payment sozusagen. Das ist schon wirklich nett.
Es sei denn, man hört irgendwas, was einem überhaupt nicht gefallen hat, aber warum hat man's dann gehört?
Genau. Ja, also insgesamt muss man sagen, in diesen ganzen Podcast-Ups, da steckt noch eine ganze Menge Verbesserungspotenzial. Ich bin eigentlich mit keiner Ab so richtig glücklich geworden. Also alle haben irgendwas. Also fast jeder Ab ist irgendwas, was ich irgendwie interessant finde oder gut gelöst finde. Aber in jeder Ab gibt's auch irgendwas, was mich zur Raserei gebracht hat. Durchgehend. Und die goldene Mischung ist zumindest jetzt für meine Bedürfnisse, your mileage may vary, noch nicht so hundertprozentig erfüllt. Aber das ist halt auch immer ganz interessant zu sehen, dass da das Rennen eigentlich auch noch total offen ist, was jetzt wirklich so der coolste Player ist. Also manche haben mehr Eyecandy, manche übertreiben es dann auch wieder.
Ich hab auch mal angefangen, eine zu schreiben.
Aber wirklich?
Weil mir auch diese iPod-App da auf den Sack gegangen ist. Aber ich muss sagen, also das ist einfach auch zu nichts gekommen. Man fängt ja überhaupt erst mal damit an, einen XML-Parser so hinzubiegen, dass er irgendwie sämtliche Feeds, die irgendwo rausfallen, dann auch versteht und irgendwie die Information zu normalisieren und so. Und dann kommt er total in den Wald mit.
Das ist wohl richtig fies, weil es einfach so viele kaputte Feeds gibt.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, weil die Standards halt auch so offen sind. Da macht halt jeder seine Tags, wie er halt gerade lustig ist. Also das ist irgendwie so... Und dann muss man den ganzen Kram runterladen. Da muss man sich mit dem Audio rumschlagen und so weiter. Ich bewundere die Leute, die da das Durchhaltevermögen haben. Und dann hast du natürlich auch so dieses Interface zu designen. Das ist gar nicht so einfach. Weil man will es eigentlich so einfach haben, wie die iPod-Applikation von Apple. Was die Einfachheit halber anbelangt, ist sie eigentlich sehr schön. Aber du willst natürlich mehr Funktionen haben. Und du willst mehr Funktionen haben, ohne dass du dir dein Interface zu glatterst. Und das ist echt schwer. Also das... Ich hab dann auch so Sachen gemacht, wie Wellenform zeichnen. Damit man auch mal so ein bisschen sieht, wo passiert was und so. Aber das ist auch... Ja, das ist ein Projekt für sich. Ja, das ist ein Projekt für sich, wenn man da so einen 3-Stunden-Podcast hat und dann will man den in 200 Pixeln darstellen. Ich meine, du hast ja dann auch so ein Pfeil von mehreren, zig Megabyte. Da musst du dann einmal durchgehen nur um eine Wellenform darzustellen.
Ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum das keiner macht.
Ja, das geht.
Da braucht man ja auch CPU für nichts und wieder nichts.
Das ist nicht so schlimm, wenn man das beim Runterladen gleich macht. Ich meine, du lädst das Ding ja eh runter. Da kannst du auch einmal schnell das MP3 einmal auspacken und gucken, was da drin ist.
Aber das musst du dann halt nicht nur für MP3, sondern auch für MP4 machen. Und für HIAC und so weiter.
Richtig. Wobei, wenn du es einmal als PCM-Stream hast, dann ist es relativ simpel.
Gibt es ja auch alles Klassen von Apple mit Core Audio und so weiter. Das sind alles Bausteine, die hat man zur Verfügung. Man kriegt das hin, aber es ist halt viel Arbeit.
Ja, ich kann ja hier nur dann noch mal sagen.
Wie hört ihr Podcasts? Downcast.
Du benutzt Downcast. Ich benutze so viele Podcasts wie noch nie, glaube ich.
Seitdem du Downcast verwendest?
Nee, ich habe auch vorher mit Instacast schon sehr viele Podcasts gehört. Aber ich finde, ich bin Downcast ein bisschen hübscher. Ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht mehr, was ich hübscher fand. Was man an dem Moment mal vielleicht mal...
Jetzt reagiert dieses Scheißteil nicht, wenn man da drauf drückt.
Was ich ganz schön finde, ist ein Dienst. Kennt ihr den?
Haft Duffer? Ja.
Das ist so ein Dienst, da kann man sich einen Account zulegen und ist quasi so ein Instapaper für Podcasts, sag ich jetzt mal. Die haben so einen Bookmarklet. Es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Chrome-Extension. Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Safari-Extension noch dafür gibt. Man legt sich einen Account an, installiert sich diese Extension und kriegt seinen eigenen, personalisierten Podcast-Feed. Den trägt man in einem Podcast-Client seiner Wahl ein. Und immer, wenn man irgendwas Spannendes findet, zum Beispiel mal wieder so ein Deutschlandfunk-Interview oder sowas, wo ich normalerweise nicht dazu gekommen bin, mir die jemals anzuhören, also das funktioniert keinem von dem PdW-Können, dann klickt man da einfach dieses Haft-Dafti-Icon in seinem Chrome, sagt, ja, lad das jetzt, trag diesen Podcast da ein oder dieses MP3. Und dann ist das ein Podcast-Feed drin und dann kann man sich das sehr bequem anhören. Das ist ganz und gerade großartig. Ist auch besonders gut geeignet, wenn man jetzt mal einfach nur ein Podcast reinhören will, ohne ihn gleich abonnieren zu müssen. Dann sucht man sich einfach eine Folge raus, die man spannend findet. Haft-Dafti...
Hafti-Dafti?
Ah, also auf jeden Fall.
Haft-Dafti und dann ist alles gut. Dafti? Haft-Daffa. Wie ist der Prozess des Haft-Daffens? Das Verb!
Hafti-Dafti klingt so nach Hamti-Damti. So ein Ei mit Feinen.
Haft-Dafti.
Man haft-daft-die Podcast-Folge.
Du solltest doch nicht so viel vernehmen. Ja, irgendwas wollte ich noch sagen zu den Podcast-Clients. Ich versuche gerade herauszufinden, ich verwechsel die halt auch immer wieder. Ich habe jetzt mit allen mal ein bisschen rumgespielt und dann kann man dann immer nicht merken, welcher jetzt eigentlich welcher ist. Also welcher quasi welchen Vorteil hatte und welchen Nachteil hatte.
Das ist auch echt alles nicht so einfach.
Aber es gibt teilweise interessante Detail-Features. Zum Beispiel so Sleep-Timer, die du einstellen kannst. Das heißt, er geht dann irgendwie automatisch aus, wenn du nicht irgendwie sagst, dass du weiterhören willst. Ich spiele eine halbe Stunde diesen Podcast ab, weil dann schlafe ich wahrscheinlich schon.
Du hörst viel vom Schlafen?
Ich benutze dieses Feature nicht, ich sage nur, dieses Feature gibt es.
Ich höre Podcasts immer nur in öffentlich-rechtlichen Verkehrsmitteln.
In öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln. Das ist interessant, ich kann Audio auch nur hören, also am besten wenn ich unterwegs bin, im allerbesten, im Bett zum Beispiel, habe ich das Problem, Audio hält mich enorm wach. Ich bin so müde, dass ich es eh nicht leuchte. Aber da man da so rumliegt und dann sowas hört, wenn man so ein bisschen aufmerksamkeitsgestört ist, dann nimmt man halt auch mal gleich sein iPhone und surft parallel irgendwo rum und hört da nicht richtig zu. Deswegen kann ich da besser eigentlich mit Video einschlafen, weil da bin ich irgendwie so komplett belegt, also Fernsehen war wirklich gut, so richtig so mach mich tot, mach mich tot.
Also ich setz mich dann vor den Fernseher und surf nebenbei noch auf dem iPad.
Ja, ich will ja im Bett einschlafen und nicht auf dem Sofa. Das find ich immer so krank.
Nee, ich schlaf früher. Früher, wenn ich die dreieinhalb Male, die ich meine Wohnung geputzt habe, dabei hab ich das ganz gerne gemacht, Podcasts gehört. So bin ich auf H2 der Tag damals gekommen in einem.
Aber diese ganzen anderen Podcast-Clines, das sind alles US-amerikanische Entwickler, oder?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, woher die alle kommen, aber... Also Podcaster find ich nicht gut. Eyecatcher weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Es gab noch einen, wie hieß der?
Es gibt Eyecatcher, es gibt Pocketcasts...
Pocketcast war es wahrscheinlich.
Pocketcast find ich...
Und es gibt Downcast und Instacast. Das sind eigentlich so diese fünf Contender.
Moment, ich hab ja hier irgendwie auch drei oder so drauf, die ich mir irgendwie alle angeguckt hab, aber...
Pocketnow Pocketcasts.
Podcasts, aber war das nicht irgendwie so einer aus dem Osten?
Pocketcast war also der allererste, der überhaupt da war. Das war der, der am Anfang auch gleich wieder rausgeflogen ist.
Das ist ja schon alles, wenn man nach Podcast sucht, dann ist Bitzone zu ganz vorne. Podcast, da welchen hatten ich noch hier? Gab es noch irgendwie noch so ein eigenes User-Interface hatte, was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so schön fand.
Also es gibt schon eine Menge User-Interfaces, die auch so ein bisschen verwirren. Da ist so einiges dabei. Was ich sehr schade finde, ist, dass sich bisher keiner dazu durchgerungen hat. Das ist auch so eine ganz alte Idee, einfach dieses iPod-Interface wieder nachzubauen.
Mit dem Drehrädchen?
Ja, oder vielleicht mal aus einer anderen Perspektive. Nicht so was für Features gibt es, sondern eigentlich was ich immer noch so vermisse. Das ist eins davon. Ich finde nach wie vor, zum Hören von Audio-Podcasts, war der iPod 5G einfach die beste Maschine, die es überhaupt je gab.
Stimmt, den hatte ich auch.
War super.
Mit diesem Rädchen und so weiter, du konntest das Ding komplett in der Hosentasche bedienen. Wenn du irgendwie Finger drauf gehalten hast, auf diesem Knopf in der Mitte und wenn du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, jemand spricht dich an oder so.
Obwohl ich sagen muss, ich traue ja immer noch dem mechanischen Scrollrad von der ersten Generation iPod hinterher. Weil wenn man das mal erlebt hat, das war wirklich super. Man konnte dieses Rad einfach so mit dem Daumen so snick und dann hat es sich gedreht. Es war ein Stück Plastik, das sich gedreht hat und das hat sich ganz anders angefühlt, dadurch, dass man wirklich was bewegt hat. Seit es diese komischen Scrollräder mit Touch gibt, die fand ich irgendwie alle furchtbar.
Ab der zweiten Generation.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, dass dieses mechanische Teil, wenn da mal Sand reinkam, war halt vorbei mit Scroll.
Du hast es über Kopf gehalten, ein bisschen gedreht und dann war der Sand wieder draußen. Ich hatte nie dieses Problem. Nein, nicht groß.
Ich fand das Touch-Wil schon okay, aber grundsätzlich das User-Interface-Rad hatte einfach diesen riesigen Vorteil, du konntest das Ding komplett in der Tasche lassen, was gerade so im Winter ein echter Vorteil ist, du musst mal kurz stopp machen, einfach in der Tasche auf diesen Punkt in der Mitte geklickt und stopp.
Aber für mal kurz stopp machen, gab es da was nicht? Ja, aber jetzt an meinem aktuellen Gerät habe ich diesen entsprechenden Knopf da auf dem Headset dran.
Am Headset.
Da mache ich eigentlich auch eine Play-Pause. Du musst aber deine Hände immer draußen haben, was im Winter echt nicht einfach ist. Kannst aber mit Handschuhen drücken. Versuch mal mit dicken Handschuhen diesen Knopf zu treffen. Viel Spaß.
Ich habe so normale Handschuhe, damit geht es.
Wie auch immer. Was auf jeden Fall mit dem iPhone nicht geht, ist mal eben 20 Sekunden zurückspulen.
Ja, das ist gruselig.
Und das ist einfach so cool gewesen mit diesem Rad. Und vor allem, du kannst jetzt einfach die Geschwindigkeit, mit der du spurst, auch einfach direkt mit dem Finger spüren, beziehungsweise steuern. Und das ist genau das, was keine App hat, keine App traut, sich mal so einen iPod-Modus zu machen. Was spricht dagegen, einfach dieses Wheel nachzubilden, dass du da mit so einer zirkulären Bewegung genau dasselbe bewirkst, dass du vor- und zurückspulen kannst? Das wär einfach super. Du hast nicht so gut im Gefühl, weil es natürlich immer noch ein glatter Bildschirm ist, aber von der Aktion her wäre es toll.
Ich fände auch eine seitliche Bewegung, die einen scrollen bewirkt, fände ich auch okay.
Da hätte ich lieber Chapter Support. Also ich hätte gerne Gesten um so Kapitel vor, Kapitel zurück, beziehungsweise bestimmte Gesten um auch so was wie eine Minute vor oder so mit drei Fingern ist so wie eine Minute vor, mit zwei Fingern ist zehn Sekunden vor oder wie auch immer kannst du einstellen. Oder eben auch so Kapitel vor und zurück, ja? Springen zum Anfang des aktuellen Kapitels. Ich will diesen Teil nochmal hören. Das sind einfach so die Dinge. Also wenn nicht jetzt als Geste, dann doch zumindest als Button. Überhaupt, dass man eben diese Kapitelinformationen besser umsetzt.
Das finde ich übrigens an dem iPod-Programm von Apple total anstrengend, dass er einem immer nur die Restzeit des aktuellen Kapitels sagt.
Ja, sowas nervt auch total, ja.
Man denkt dann, ah, noch drei Minuten, der Podcast ist gleich zu Ende und dann läuft er noch Stunden.
Ja, ist das furchtbar. Also mit dem iPhone ist wirklich eine Menge schlechter geworden. Aber das hatten wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt. Durchaus. Was neben dem Kapitelinterface mir einfach auch noch fehlt, ist eine bessere Integration der Show Notes. Also zum Beispiel bei Instacast hast du das Problem, der zeigt dir, du kannst da zwar hin navigieren zu den Show Notes und da dann Play drücken, aber dieser eigentliche Play-Dialog, der dann sich so da drüber schiebt, der ist unabhängig davon. Das heißt, wenn du danach irgendwie in deinen Podcast hin und her suchst und dann woanders bist, gibt es keine Möglichkeit mal eben die Show Notes dessen, was gerade spielt, anzugucken. Du musst dann den suchen und nichts hilft dir dabei. Du hast da irgendwie eine Liste mit 20 Podcasts. Jeder hat irgendwie zehn Episoden und weiß jetzt gar nicht, in welcher Reihenfolge das ist, ob du nach oben oder nach unten scrollen sollst. Nichts sagt dir, hier sind die Show Notes zu dem aktuell spielenden Ding. Manche Sachen, ich hab jetzt gerade geguckt, welcher das war. Ich glaube, das war am besten gelöst bei... Was hab ich schon wieder vergessen? War das Downcast oder war das Cast?
Bei Downcast gibt es immer so einen Now Playing-Button, genauso wie im iPad. Und wenn du den drückst, dann bist du bei dem, was gerade läuft.
Und kommen da auch diese Show Notes. Welcher ist denn, der dir das Icon immer so klein macht?
Also so sieht Downcast hier aus, falls ich das mal kurz zeigen darf. Was ich bei Downcast vermisse, ist eine Liste der neuesten Podcasts. Also was ist als letztes hinzugekommen? Vielleicht gibt es das noch irgendwo als Einstellung, aber ich finde das immer nicht. Und die sind dann halt auch nicht... Wär schön, wenn die dann wenigstens sortiert werden oder sowas. Also am liebsten wäre mir ein Eintrag mit neuesten Podcasts.
Ja, aber der nimmt jetzt hier zum Beispiel das ganze JavaScript, was da irgendwie mit drin ist, stellt er auch noch irgendwie da. Aber der hat Gesten wiederum. Interessant. Aber was bewirken die Gesten?
Ja.
Das krollt ein bisschen nach vorne. Und ich glaube, bei Eyecatcher war das auch noch irgendwie gelöst. Also das sind so diese kleinen Sachen, die mich stören. Und wo du das gerade sagst, so dynamische Listen, was hattest du gerade gesagt, was gerade läuft?
Nee, das neueste, die neuesten Sachen, die ich zeigte.
Achso, genau, wie sie reingekommen sind.
Quasi, also so, hey.
Das hast du wiederum bei Instacast. Was aber bei Instacast auch nicht hast, ist so eine Liste der letzten, die du gehört hast. Weil das ist immer das, was ich will. Ich spreng aber so zwischen zwei oder drei Podcasts hin und her. ZB hab einen gehört und will dann da vielleicht noch mal auf die Show Notes zu. Und das Programm merkt sich für mich nicht, was ich so recently played habe. Weil das ist eigentlich eine Liste, die ich permanent wieder konsultieren möchte. Playlisten haben dann wiederum andere Sachen.
Also da kannst du auf jeden Fall auch Playlisten nutzen.
Genau, genau. Wobei, was man damit halt ganz gut machen kann, ist sowas wie... Manchmal möchte ich gerne das Neueste aus einem bestimmten Podcast-Network hören. Was weiß ich, du gruppierst dir deine Podcasts, die du abonniert hast, so von Twitter oder von 5x5 oder so. Oder meinetwegen auch Metaebene. Dann könntest du eben diese Podcasts gruppieren und in dieser Playlist anzeigen lassen. Zeig mir an, was in dieser Auswahl so und so sortiert jetzt irgendwie die aktuelle Situation ist. Also da ist auf jeden Fall noch eine Menge Verbesserungspotenzial. Und ich find die alle zu billig. Ja, ich mach mir da echt Sorgen. Dass die sich alle...
Dass die sich gegenseitig raushauen.
Naja, dass die sich damit finanzieren können. Ich meine, die kosten irgendwie alle so einen Dollar oder zwei. Das ist doch echt kein Geld.
Ach, sollen sie lieber mehr verkaufen. Kauft euch alle...
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde lieber 10 Euro dafür ausgeben und dann ist es irgendwie auch ordentlich.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert schon, dass wenn es ein bisschen billiger ist, dass man dann auch ein bisschen mehr verkauft.
Nee. Nicht unbedingt. Aber Preisfindung ist sowieso eine Wissenschaft für sich. Schwierig. Schwarze Magie könnte man fast schon sagen.
Naja, was haben wir hier noch so Schönes?
Wir könnten jetzt mal auf die Nerd-Themen kommen.
Nach so allgemeinen Mainstream-Themen wie Kalender. Ja, worauf denn?
Naja, ZFS.
Aber Denis ist doch gar nicht da.
Ja, aber Roddi ist da.
Ich bin da. Ja, jetzt ist die Frage, was will man groß zu ZFS erzählen?
Naja, wir haben ja nun seit Ewigkeiten geheult. Dann haben wir irgendwann festgestellt, dass es eine Firma gibt, die mal in Aussicht gestellt hat, dass es ZFS geben könnte irgendwann mal vielleicht. Diese Tenz-Komplement-Bude. Und zuletzt haben wir glaube ich Berichte, dass sie angekündigt haben, dass sie mit diesem Produkt rauskommen wollen. Und jetzt ist es draußen.
Zumindest die sogenannte Silver Edition, wo man nur einzelne Laufwerke zu einem einzelnen Z-Pool verbauen kann. Also das muss man jetzt wahrscheinlich erklären. Muss man das erklären?
Ohne jetzt gleich zu tief zu gehen.
Ohne zu tief einzugehen. Das Prinzip von ZFS ist ja, dass man einen sogenannten Z-Pool hat. So eine Art Storage-Pool, aus dem man dann Speicherplatz nimmt, um darauf ZFS-Fallsysteme draufzusetzen. Und dieser Z-Pool, den kann man entweder aus einem einzelnen Laufwerk machen, also aus einem einzelnen Laufwerk bauen, oder aus einer Mirror-Konfiguration, aus einer Raid-Konfiguration. Es sind sogar noch komplexere Strukturen möglich. Ich selber hab mal ein Mirror aus Mirrors gebaut, was relativ gut funktioniert. Also du hast vier Laufwerke, dann hast du paarweise zu einem Mirror zusammen.
Warum nennt er ein Mirror von Mirrors?
Nein, das war ein Stripe von Mirrors. Also je ein Pärchen von Laufwerken gemirroert und diese beiden Mirror zu einem großen Laufwerk zusammen gestript.
Also ausfallsicher und schnell.
Ausfallsicher und schnell. Zumindest eine Platte kann auf jeden Fall abbrauchen. Zwei Platten können abbrauchen, wenn es die richtigen sind. Schnell, ja, auf jeden Fall. Und ja, das funktioniert gut. Also man hat bei der Konfiguration außerdem noch den Vorteil, dass die beiden Pärchen unterschiedliche Größen haben können. Also ich kann jetzt zwei 500er Platte zu einem Mirror zusammentun und zwei 1TB Platten zu einem Mirror zusammentun. Und wenn ich die beiden Mirror zu einem Stripe zusammentu, habe ich 1,5TB. Und ich kann jetzt aber auch sagen, okay, ich kaufe mir jetzt zwei 2TB Platten und tausche jetzt eine 500er gegen eine 2TB Platte aus, warte bis die sich da beruhigt haben, re-silvert haben, wie man so schön sagt, tausche dann die zweite 2TB Platte durch die 500er aus und habe dann plötzlich 3TB in meinem Pool, wenn der damit re-silvert fertig ist. Also es geht, das ist irgendwie, das ist nicht so ein Problem. Was hab ich noch gebaut? Ich hab mal, ich hab aus 6 Platten ein Raid Z2 Pool gebaut. Also Raid Z ist wie ein normales Raid mit einer Platte, die ausfallen kann und Raid Z2 ist halt wie ein Raid 5.
Also wie ein Raid 5.
Wie ein Raid 5, also Raid Z ist wie ein Raid 5 und Raid Z2 ist wie ein Raid 5, aber mit einer doppelten Ausfallsicherheit. Ich glaub man nennt es Raid 6 oder so. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Also zumindest hat man zwei Platten, die ausfallen können und es funktioniert trotzdem noch. Interessanterweise sind diese Raid-Verbünde, was das Lesen anbelangt, trotzdem relativ flott, weil man ja trotzdem parallel von allen Platten liest. Also schreiben, klar, aber lesen dadurch, dass das ja nur ein Teil der Daten auf den jeweiligen Platten ist, ist das trotzdem relativ flott. Also das ist irgendwie, man sagt ja mal Raid wäre langsam, aber das geht eigentlich ganz gut.
Nö, gerade die Redundanz erlaubt ja das parallele Lesen. Ich meine, das hast du ja sonst bei dem...
Ja bei dem Mirror sowieso. Da kann man ja komplett unterschiedliche Sachen lesen.
Also interessant, dass du so die Konfigurierbarkeit von ZFS so als erstes Feature präsentierst, als das Interessanteste. Ich finde ja ganz andere Sachen interessanter.
Was heißt das Interessanteste? Ich habe jetzt einfach nur beschrieben, da ist dieser Storage Pool und diesen Storage Pool kann man in verschiedenen Konfigurationen aus verschiedenen Arten von Platten zusammenbauen. Das ist einfach jetzt mal ein Teil dieses Pools. Da drauf, die Fallsysteme an sich, die haben ja auch nochmal interessante Eigenschaften. Aber ich bin jetzt mal von unten lang gegangen. Was auch sehr interessant ist, ist, dass jeder Block in ZFS eine Checksumme hat. Und zwar wirklich jeder logische Block hat eine Checksumme. Das heißt, wenn irgendwo eine Platte anfängt, Bitfehler zu machen, dann weiß ZFS auch ganz genau, welche Platte die Bitfehler macht.
Und wo.
Und wo. Also wenn man einen stumpfen Mirror-Controller irgendwo hat, der plötzlich feststellt, dass seine beiden Festplatten unterschiedliche Dinge sagen, der kann dann nicht sagen, ja, aber welches ist jetzt das Richtige? Aber das muss man sich vergegenwärtigen.
Und nicht nur das. Es gibt auch, also ich hab von so Large Deployments von ZFS gelesen, wo sie mal wirklich so auch eine große Infrastruktur von Platten verbinden und so durch ZFS ersetzt haben. Wo es also vorher ohne Checksum war, dann mit Checksum. Wo sie dann erstmal festgestellt haben, wo überhaupt diese Fehler auftreten. Und das waren gar nicht mal nur die Platten. Es waren teilweise auch die Controller und die Leitungen, wo die Bits verloren gegangen sind.
Und Netzteile, auch ein ganz bekannter Fehler. Oder ein beliebter Fehler. Wenn du erstmal so einen Rechner hast, wo du 6 Platten reinschraubst, die plötzlich alle auf Volldampf anfangen, Daten zu ziehen. Dann kriegst du natürlich auch so Spitzenlast, Stromverbrauchsszenarien, wo dir halt irgendwie die eine Platte, die das am wenigsten abkann, plötzlich immer so millisekundenlang die Hufe hochnimmt und irgendwie Schrott auf die eigene Platte schreibt. Und das findest du dann halt erst heraus, wenn du sämtliche Kabel getauscht hast und sonst was getauscht hat. Und dann sagt jemand auf der Mailing nächste Jahr, wie ist denn das mit dem Netzteil? Und dann tauscht der Mensch das Netzteil und sagt, ach ja, jetzt ist es weg.
Naja, also things fail und gerade bei den eigenen Daten will man das ja nun wirklich überhaupt nicht haben. Das fand ich auch so von Anfang an eigentlich immer so eines der charming, most charming Arguments für ZFS. Man kann sich einfach seiner Daten sicher sein. Also es gibt keine Garantie dafür, dass alles überlebt. Aber man weiß zumindest, wenn etwas kaputt ist, wo es kaputt ist und in welchem Umfang es kaputt ist. Und gerade in solchen Mirror-Situationen kann ZFS auch selber korrigieren. Also es ist ja auch gar nicht mal so, wenn jetzt so ein Bit umgekippt ist, heißt das ja nicht, dass die Platte kaputt ist. Das heißt, dass dieser Sektor kaputt ist, also nicht mehr die Daten enthält, die irgendwann mal draufgeschrieben wurden. Man kann sie dann einfach wieder überschreiben und alles ist okay, ja. Things happen und Bits purzeln. Es ist halt auch alles nur Magnetismus. Und in dem Moment, wo eben von einem Mirror zwei eigentlich identische Blöcke gelesen werden und ZFS stellt fest, so hm, da ist aber der eine falsch, dann nimmt er halt das Richtige und schreibt es eben bei dem anderen einfach wieder richtig. Und dann hat es auch so eine selbst heilende Kraft. Wo ich ein richtig weich geworden bin, damit können wir das jetzt vielleicht auch erstmal diesen Overview für die Leute, die jetzt noch gar nicht wissen, warum wir die ganze Zeit so hyperventilieren und Schnappatmung kriegen bei diesem Thema. Das ist halt dieses Versprechen der Data-Deduplication. Also, wir wiederholen uns hier ein gewisses Händsel.
Tim hat schon gesagt Versprechen.
Ja, es ist ein Versprechen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der jetzige Zustand ist, aber es gibt Leute, die sind damit doch auch ganz unschön gefahren, weil die Tabelle, die ZFS aufbauen muss, um festzustellen, welche Blocks sind denn nun deduplizierbar oder nicht, die kann schon mal sehr groß werden. Und das kann sich zur großen Bremse herausstellen. Also es gibt Leute, die haben feststellen müssen, dass ihr ZFS, nachdem sie Deduplication angeschaltet haben, irgendwie nur noch ein Zehntel so schnell war. Und es ging auch nicht weg, wenn man es wieder abgeschaltet hat.
War das jetzt ein RAM-Problem oder nur ein Look-Up-Problem?
Keine Ahnung.
Also der RAM-Bedarf steigt enorm?
Ja, ZFS braucht sowieso Massiv-RAM. Also vor allen Dingen braucht es massiv Kernel-RAM. Also das ist was, wo das muss man wissen. Und der RAM-Bedarf, der scheint auch fast linear mit der Größe der Fallsysteme, also der Größe der Platten und vor allen Dingen den Befüllungsgrad der Platten zu steigen. Ich hab da den einen FreeBSD-Server, den hab ich auf 32-Bit damals installiert, was völliger Unsinn ist. Sollte man immer auf 64-Bit installieren. Der ist mir jeder Nacht abgeraucht. Ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Da hab ich Platten getauscht, dann wurde das alles größer. Da hab ich mehr Daten drauf gespielt. Und plötzlich ist das Ding immer nachts ausgestiegen. Immer ne kernel panic. Und irgendwann hab ich dann angefangen, langsam die Daten wieder runterzumoven. Und als das belegte Dateisystem die Größe unterschritten hat, wurde er wieder stabil. Also das ist was... Da bin ich inzwischen auch so ein bisschen am Zweifeln, ob das alles so gut ist. Man muss sich auf jeden Fall bei ZFS, man braucht viel, viel...
Ja gut, aber im Chat kommt es auch gerade so 2 GB RAM pro Terabyte. Da sage ich nur, okay, meinetwegen.
2 GB RAM pro Terabyte für DDoP. Das kann durchaus sein, ja.
Also diese...
Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, ein halbes GB pro Terabyte, wenn man kein DDoP hat. Ungefähr. Jetzt mal so ganz blau über den Daumen gepeilt. Ins Blau hinaus. Aber das kann durchaus sein, ja. Das ist für DDoP. Ob es dieses DDoP wirklich letzten Endes dann so bringt, das weiß ich nicht. Das muss man mal testen. Ich hab selber... Also FreeBSD 8.2 hatte ja noch nicht die ZFS-Version, die das DDoP kann. Es ist FreeBSD 9. Und da hab ich den einen Server erst...
Das ist jetzt gerade rausgekommen, oder?
Ja, das hab ich ein paar Tage nachdem's draußen war, hab ich's mal geupdatet. Ohne Probleme. Als der Pool dann auf die neue Version geupdatet wurde, da hat das Ewigkeiten gedauert, bis der irgendwie an Performance, an Fahrt aufgenommen hat. Aber seitdem läuft der eigentlich ohne Probleme. Keine Ahnung. Ich hab das aber auch noch nicht genau angeguckt.
Also ich hätte ja gerne so ein System, was die Duplication macht, einfach um Platz zu sparen. Weil, okay, pro Terabyte und so, man spart da halt auch eine Menge Terabyte, wenn man das hat. Also gerade bei sowas wie Time Machine Backups, wo einfach immer wieder alles doppelt ist, du änderst irgendwie ein Bit an einer Datei und die ganze Datei wird neu geschrieben und wenn die Datei halt 100 Gigabyte groß ist, dann werden halt 100 Gigabyte geschrieben. Und das ist natürlich auch, ich weiß nicht, ob das absehbar ist, dass sich das irgendwann mal ändert.
Nicht bei 10.7 also.
Nein, bei 10.7 hat sich nichts geändert, aber es ist jetzt nicht komplett unmöglich, dass sich das ändert. Gerade wenn man sich mal anschaut, was sie jetzt mit ihren Diffs machen für Autosave. Weil das sind also Binary Diffs.
Ich hab gerade bei Time Machine so das Gefühl, Apple hat damals irgendwie ZFS unter die Finger gekriegt und hat gesehen, oh, Snapshots, haben wir noch nicht erklärt. Man kann einfach sagen, jetzt friere diesen Zustand des Dateisystems ein, nennt sich Snapshot. Und alles, was sich dann ändert, wird halt zusätzlich geschrieben. Aber man kann diesen Snapshot, diesen Zustand des Dateisystems wieder hervorgraben, wenn man ihn irgendwie braucht. So und ich hab so das Gefühl gehabt, Apple hat gesehen, ja, ZFS, das machen wir. Da können wir mit Snapshots, können wir schön Backup und so weiter machen. Und haben angefangen, da dieses Time Machine Backup aus der Taufe zu heben. Und dann fiel ihnen irgendwie auf, naja, das mit dem ZFS, das wird doch nicht so schnell. Da stand bestimmt Steve in der Tür und hat gesagt, ich will aber das Backup haben, mach das irgendwie anders, mach das. Und dann sind sie auf diese, diesen Irrsinn mit den verlinkten, verhardlinkten Dateien verfallen.
Naja, also ich glaube, das hängt nicht so direkt miteinander zusammen. Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, sie haben einfach den Bedarf gesehen, Backup. Den gab's. Niemand macht Backups. Und man kann an Time Machine rumkritteln, was man will, es ist da.
Es hat auf jeden Fall das User Interface, was eine Backup-Solution immer haben sollte. Es gibt nur einen Einschalter und fertig. Und ansonsten wird alles gebackupped. Das ist einfach meiner Meinung nach die große Leistung von Time Machine. Ich muss nichts konfigurieren, ich steck die Platte ran, ich schalte ein und dann hab ich einen Backup. So muss ein Backup halt einfach sein. Weil sonst macht man's nicht.
Ja, zurück zu dem ZFS, das heißt jetzt CWO. Kann man kaufen in dieser Silver Edition? Kostet das 29 Dollar oder so? Oder 19? Das weiß ich gerade gar nicht, aber wenig.
Ich glaub, das sind 19 Dollar, was irgendwie auf 15 Euro runterkommt. Also, wie gesagt, diese Silver Edition, die kann eben nur einzelne Platten, die kann kein Mirroring, die kann kein Ray-Z, keinen sonstigen Kram für ihre Z-Pools. Die kann, oh Gott, jetzt müsste ich selber gucken, die kann, glaub ich, keine automatischen Snapshots, die kann kein De-Duplication.
Die kann keine Snapshots?
Keine automatischen Snapshots.
Ach so.
Ab der Gold Edition, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe, machen sie, kannst du dann sagen, ja, mach halt alle so und so viel in Snapshot.
Wo ist denn diese Vergleichsliste geblieben?
Ja, was jetzt mit der ist, das ist mal gut. Also hier ist Silver Edition.
Ah, hier ist die Vergleichsgeschichte.
Was meinen sie denn mit Data Checkups?
Das ist ein Scrub, was bei ZFS Scrub heißt. Also sprich, ZFS geht einmal durch den gesamten Pool durch. Und prüft die Checksum von allen Blöcken. Das nennt sich Scrub und wenn dann halt Checksum nicht stimmen, dann und so weiter.
Das heißt, man merkt sofort, wenn was ist und nicht erst, wenn drauf zugegriffen wird.
Genau.
Und keine Snapshot-Options. Wobei es eben so aussieht, als ob eigentlich der Treiber darunter im Wesentlichen immer derselbe ist. Nur, dass sie ins User-Interface diese Sachen nicht hinein publizieren. Und die Command-Line-Sachen, so sind die jetzt eigentlich mit dabei. Wenn ich die richtig verstanden hab, sind die jetzt dabei. Ich hab hier ein ZFS-Command und jetzt auf meinem Computer. Und ich hab mich jetzt nicht sehr viel damit beschäftigt, aber Leute schrieben so Sachen, wie sie hätten mit dieser Silver-Edition ZFS-Filesystem gemacht, das dann mal auch an so einem Free-Base-D ran gehängt, da auch D-Duplication eingeschaltet, und das mountete alles immer noch. Und es sah auch so aus, als ob diese D-Duplication eingeschaltet sei. Also es macht den Eindruck, ich kann da jetzt noch nicht mal ein Handwins-File legen. Denis ist ja auch im Chat, vielleicht kannst du ja noch mal was beitragen von der Seite. Aber ich hab so den Eindruck, dass das schon eigentlich alles könnte, nur eben nicht unbedingt alles ins User-Interface exposed ist, aber dass man so auf der Kommando-Zeile eigentlich alles machen kann, was man so möchte.
Ja, also ich hab ja die letzte, die letzte Developer-Beta oder die letzte Beta da ausprobiert und das tat schon irgendwie alles vor allen Dingen, was ich sehr angenehm fand. Ich hatte nicht eine Colonel Panic, was irgendwie mit dem Mac ZFS, dass da die Jungs auf GitHub zusammengeschraubt haben, wo ich ja auch eine Weile mal dabei war, aber nur ganz am Anfang. Da hat man schon da so die eine oder andere Colonel Panic, die hat man da schon. Und die Betas von Apple, die waren ja noch viel schlimmer. Also da hat man der Platte irgendwie was Neues draufgeschrieben, weil man sagte, ich will jetzt doch kein Fallsystem von ZFS und dann war der Rechner weg.
Hier kommt die Frage, kann man da von booten? Nein, kann man nicht, weil dazu müsstest du es halt nehmen.
Also Boot-Support ist was, das wird auch, denke ich, mal so schnell nicht kommen. Also weil dazu müsste ja Apple oder Arbatens Komplement überhaupt erst mal einen ZFS-fähigen Bootloader schreiben. Das ist ja was, was wohl auch bei FreeBSD erst relativ spät kam.
Ich glaube, da kann man noch sehr lange drauf warten. Es ist jetzt schon vollkommen unklar, welche Zukunft dieses Produkt hat. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich, dass es insofern zukunftssicher ist, dass man davon ausgehen kann, dass jetzt nicht irgendwelche dramatischen Änderungen anstehen. Mac OS-Handy dann jetzt ZFS komplett ausschließen, wenn es gleich auch Anpassungen geben mag auf neue OS.
Glaube ich auch nicht, weil eigentlich müsste Apple ja ein Interesse daran haben, dass so ein Produkt auch angeboten wird und dass das auch gut funktioniert.
Das bindet sich ja letztlich auch ein als ein weiteres Fallsystem von zahlreichen, die ja heute schon unterstützt werden. Also man hat ja auch DOS-Gramm.
ZFS als Fallsystem zu bezeichnen, ist halt immer so eine Sache, weil dieses mit dem Z-Pool und auf dem Z-Pool dann die Dateilsysteme ist halt eine dermaßen komplexe Lösung, dass man von diesem traditionellen Fallsystembegriff eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig sprechen kann.
Meistens ist es mehr so ein Fallsystem OS.
Und wenn man so hört, was wohl auch die ZFS, die Freebase, die Jungs, was die für einen Aufwand betrieben haben, um das einzubauen, dass die da irgendwie einen halben Körner umgeschrieben haben, ist es halt einfach extrem aufwendig auch, das richtig hinzukriegen, weil es halt so ein massives Stück Code ist auch.
Aber das bringt uns auf einen anderen interessanten Punkt. Seit LINE gibt es ja ein neues Subsystem in Mac OS X. Core Storage, was so den Eindruck macht, als ob das so die Basis zukünftiger Dateisystemverbesserungen sein wird. Also da wird jetzt schon eine ähnliche Sprache gesprochen.
Immerhin ist Core Storage in der Lage, von einem Disk Image zu booten. Das muss man erst mal sich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Also der Lion Installer, den ich mir unter Snow Leopard runter lade, der wird ja auch von dem Disk Image gebootet. Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, kann natürlich sein, dass sie zuerst die Platte neu partitionieren, um diese komische Restore-Partition anzulegen und dann booten sie von der Restore-Partition mit der Information, wo das Disk Image von dem Installer ist. Aber es kann auch sein, dass sie direkt das Disk Image booten, da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher. Also dieses Core Storage, das muss man im Auge behalten, das wird noch interessant.
Auf jeden Fall ist es ja jetzt schon so, dass die Platte jetzt unter Mac OS X sich so präsentiert. Du hast halt Logical Volume Groups. Ja, das ist schon eine neue Sprache. Also die Idee eines Logical Volumes heißt ja schon mal, dass man eben auch mehrere Platten vielleicht zusammen fasst. Das muss nicht so sein. Derzeit sieht das halt einfach so aus. Also das ist jetzt quasi die Sicht, die das Betriebssystem darauf hat. Auf der Platte stehen natürlich nach wie vor dasselbe. Das ist einfach HFS+, aber die Art und Weise, wie es vom Betriebssystem aufgenommen wird, ist ja zeugend so eine Logical Volume Group. Darin befinden sich dann eben ein oder mehrere Physical Volumes, eben dann eben diese Partition. Da sieht man schon, also das ist für Mirrors und für Stripes und all diese ganzen Systeme eigentlich die Basisarbeit gelegt. Das zu zusammenfassen. Und dann definieren sie innerhalb dieser Volume Group eine Volume Family, eine Logical Volume Family, in der sich dann wiederum ein oder mehrere Logical Volumes befinden, die dann eben so Items sind, die man so mounted. Und so ist das jetzt erstmal ausgelegt. Aber da sind auch schon so Sachen wie File Vault, Verschlüsselungen etc. alles mit angelegt. Sprich, all diese Neuerungen, die jetzt kamen, wie File Vault 2, ist konzeptionell basiert das eben auf diesem Core Storage.
Genau.
So und ich könnte mir halt jetzt sehr wohl vorstellen bzw. halte eigentlich das schon für absehbar, weil warum sollten sie sonst diesen Weg jetzt einschlagen, dass all diese Features, die sie von ZFS gerne hätten, von denen sie wissen, dass sie eigentlich wünschenswert sind? Und da würde ich jetzt mal Check-Zooming als allererstes nennen, weil das wäre schon mal ein riesen Gewinn, wenn das drin wäre. Snapshots wäre das zweite, was auch ein riesen Gewinn wäre, gerade für ihre lokale Time Machine Geschichte, aber daneben auch so weitergehende Geschichten wie das, was wir gerade gesprochen haben, meinetwegen bis hin zu Digital Obligation. Ja, warum nicht? Also gerade für Leute, die mit... Klar, man muss dieses Ram-Problem irgendwie in den Griff kriegen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwie einen anderen Ansatz gibt, als den den ZFS da beschritten hat, um das Problem zu lösen. Ich weiß eh gar nicht, warum da so viel im Ram gehalten werden muss. Weil irgendwie...
Ich glaube, man muss sich vor Augen halten, dass dieses ZFS ja ursprünglich mal von Sun gebaut wurde. Und Sun macht, wie man so schön sagt, Big Iron. Da machst du nicht mit 2TB rum. Da machst du nicht mit 10TB rum. Sondern da baust du Server im 3-stelligen Terabytes-Storage-Bereich. Das sind halt so Teile, wo du halt 30 Laufwerke reinschieben kannst. Wo du dann eben auch deine 30 GB Ram oder so da drin hast, in der Kiste. Für solche Maschinen ist dieses Pfeilsystem, Pfeilbetriebssystem ausgelegt. Es ist nicht für ich stöpsel mal eben meine 2,5 Zoll Mittenehme Festplatte an. Dafür ist es nicht gemacht. Und ich glaube, dass Apple auch genau über dieses Problem gestolpert ist. Warum sie es dann doch nicht gemacht haben, ist, dass es eben überhaupt nicht für den Anwendungsfall von Apple gebaut ist. Sondern das ist halt für ich schmeiß mir meinen Schrank voll mit Platten gebaut. Dafür ist es gemacht. wenn du so einen Storage Pool von 100 Terra, von 200 Terabyte aufbauen willst, und würdest du es jetzt aber mit einem, weiß ich nicht, wie die Hersteller heißen, die solche Kisten so als zum reinstellen mit Raid verkaufen, dann ist da natürlich auch so viel Speicher auf den Controllern. Weil die natürlich auch ganz viel zwischenspeichern. Die wollen ja auch schnell sein. Da zählt ja Durchsatz. Und dann ist es egal. Also in so einen Server steckst du eben so viel Speicher rein, weil die Kiste soll halt performen.
Ja, du hast recht. Deswegen denke ich eben, dass sie jetzt das Problem aufbrechen. Sie gehen nicht so mit diesem großen Bagger bei ZFS, Solution for Everything, sie bauen es schrittweise in ihr Betriebssystem ein und irgendwie in SnowLion, ich hoffe ja immer noch, dass es SnowLion heißt, in SnowLion kommt dann erstmal optional so CheckZooming. Weil sie jetzt einfach eine Architektur haben, auf der sie ihre eigenen Fallsysteme auch so virtualisieren können.
Das Problem an Fallsystem ist ja, da willst du eigentlich nicht ran. Weil, also ich habe ja mal bei dieser Firma Ableton gearbeitet und da gab es immer eine Beta-Phase, wenn so ein Programm rauskam und in der Beta-Phase wurden immer Preise ausgelobt für Bugs, die man gefunden hat. Und da gab es drei Klassen von Bugs. Der erste Bug war Fehlverhalten des Programms irgendwie. Der zweite, die zweite Klasse war CrashBug. Und die dritte Klasse war Dokumentzerstörer-Bug. Und genau das ist der Punkt. Ein File-System hält die Daten des Users. Wenn du ein neues File-System baust, da ist ein Bug drin und du zerschrotest von deinen Users die ganzen Daten, dann hast du ein echtes Problem. Das heißt, du willst ein File-System immer so konservativ angehen, diese ganze Entwicklung, dass du dir 100-101% sicher sein kannst, dass die Daten von deinem User sicher sind. Und da ist jetzt dieses ZFS, das hat jetzt auch 15 Jahre auf dem Buckel, grob geschätzt. Ich weiß es nicht genau, wahrscheinlich stimmt es nicht. Vielleicht sind es auch nur 10, aber das hat jetzt einfach ein paar Jahre auf dem Buckel und die hat es auch gebraucht, um eine Qualität zu bekommen. Und, äh, ich hab da ein bisschen Angst, wenn Apple jetzt hingeht und sagt, wir bauen ein neues File-System oder wir patchen das Feature X auf.
Ja, hast du FileVault eingeschaltet? Ja, da ist jedes fucking Bit auf deiner Platte jetzt anders.
Das ist jetzt verschlüsselt?
Genau. Das ist sogar, wenn da irgendwie ein Bit verloren geht, nämlich das von deinem Schlüssel, ein Bit, dann ist auch gleich alles weg. Und nicht nur ein Dokument. Also das ist schon eine ziemliche Hardcore-Änderung. Und wenn sie jetzt in demselben Ansatz, wie sie FileVault 2 einschaltbar machen, auch ein Check-Zooming einschaltbar machen, dass du einfach nochmal so ein Layer dazwischen hast, der einfach sagt, alles nochmal mit Check-Zoom. So wie jetzt alles einmal verschlüsselt ist. Und da drauf hast du dann dein HFS Plus, so wie es war. Und die ganze Software sieht nichts anderes als das. Und du hast es isoliert in diesem Layer, dann wär das schon drin. Snapshot ist ein anderes Ding, weil da musst du wirklich die ganze Struktur deines Datalsystems neu ordnen.
Snapshots wird Apple nicht hinkriegen. Also zumindest nicht sinnvoll so auf einmal mal eben. Das ist, glaube ich...
Max ist gelangweilt. Wir müssen, glaube ich, ihm mal voranschreiten.
Ich probiere hier 10.7.3 zu installieren, bei mir gibt es das aber noch nicht.
10.7.3? Wie ist das gerade redist worden?
Also bei mir nicht.
Eine Kleinigkeit noch. Dieses Cevo scheint noch wirklich Probleme zu haben mit Pools, die mehr aus einer Platte bestehen.
Wie du gerade festgestellt hast.
Wie ich hier, ja ich hatte ja so ein paar Festplatten mitgebracht, um das mal zu demonstrieren, aber es hat natürlich gleich nicht geklappt.
Aber sie sagten das ja auch, oder? Ich meine, das ist ja das, was in den Redaktionen drin steht.
Naja, Silver geht ja nur mit einer Platte. Und Gold und Platinum geht halt eben nicht. Und ich hab so ein bisschen auch den Verdacht, dass das Problem mehr so auf der Apple-Seite ist, als auf der Tenz-Complement-Seite. Weil, naja, der Finder, wie der sich immer verhält, und dieser ganze andere Layer Kram. Und da kommen zwei Laufwerke. Ah, da müssen ja auch zwei Volumes sein. Das sieht aber komisch aus, was da kommt. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, es ist allerdings wirklich auch nur eine wilde Spekulation, dass sie da vielleicht mit 10.73 noch was gefixt haben und sie Gold nicht rausbringen, bevor nicht 10.73 da ist. Aber das ist wie gesagt nur eine Spekulation.
Jetzt kommt 10.73, alles wird gut.
Ja, bestimmt.
Ich hab's noch mal noch nicht. Ich hab übrigens gerade noch jemand per Twitter, und zwar, wie heißt der? Der Diable hat einen tollen Tipp gegeben für Downcast. Man kann nämlich da doch die neuesten Podcasts sich sehen lassen. Man legt einfach eine Playlist an. Man kann bei der Playlist sagen, packt alle Podcasts rein und sortiert die umgekehrt nach Alphabet. Und schon hat man die neuesten Podcasts vorne. Also umgekehrt nach Unterlattdatum. Sehr geil. So, und ihr habt jetzt hier lange über...
Ja, also ich denke, wir werden bei Kostorich jetzt in jedem US-Release neue, also in jedem Release nach der 10 Änderungen sehen. Jetzt sicherlich nicht in 10.7.3, but you never know.
Also ich sag mal, die Bottom-Line ist C, wo im Prinzip haben wollen, aber... Bleiben wir dabei, oder?
So, vielleicht noch eine Kleinigkeit. Ich hab hier ja regelmäßig über meine Fritz-Box gestöhnt. Insbesondere, weil sie mir immer meinen Back-to-my-Mac hier irgendwie kaputt gemacht hat, was mich zum Wahnsinn getrieben hat und ich schon irgendwie alle Wege versucht habe, Alternativen zu finden. Dann bin ich jetzt mal drauf gestoßen worden, es gibt da so eine Labor-Firmware, die so ein bisschen nach Beta klingt, aber die eigentlich genau genommen immer nur so das neuere Release von eigentlich fertigen Features sind, die sie aber aus anderen Gründen irgendwie noch nicht in den Mainstream pushen wollen. Plus so noch ein paar extra Features, die man so findet, die in den normalen nicht drin sind. Unter anderem kann man den DNS-Server damit einstellen. Hurra! Und siehe da, ich habe diese Labor-Firmware installiert. Also das gibt es aber auch nur hier für das Top-Modell. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, für diese 73, 90 oder so. Und seitdem geht auch mein Back-to-my-Mac wieder.
Roddi hat schon hier seinen App.
Ich könnte jetzt den Update-Button drücken, aber ich lass das mal.
Echt, sind sie mit drei? Wir können die ganze Sendung hier runterfahren. So mal ein paar schöne Upstore-Downloads hier, damit wir die Leitung dicht kriegen, damit der Stream nicht mehr läuft.
Ich hab ja keinen!
Hier!
Software Update doesn't have any software for your computer at this time. Wieso zeigt der das bei mir nicht an?
Vielleicht hast du einen anderen Computer.
Ich hab einen anderen Computer, aber ich hab den besseren Computer. Da muss das eigentlich vor euch kommen.
Aber du wolltest ja eigentlich über die Fritzbox reden.
Erzähl mal über die Fritzbox.
Ich bin schon fertig eigentlich mit der Fritzbox. Sehr viel mehr gibt's da nicht zu sagen.
Seitdem kannst du jetzt back to your Mac.
Funktioniert jetzt wieder. Auf einmal sind meine Rechner auch von außen wieder zu sehen. Keine Ahnung, was sie da gefixt haben. I don't know, but now it works. Ich hatte ja, kann man vielleicht noch mal drauf hinweisen, wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat, hier mit dem Clemens irgendwie ein CRE gemacht, das letzte CRE, 191.
Ich hab den gehört.
Du hast den gehört.
Mit Clemens wem?
Hast du was gelernt dabei?
Ja.
Hast du auch eine Fritz-Box zu Hause?
Hast du auch geguckt, wie viel deine Leitung könnte?
Ich hab ja als einer der allerersten in Berlin Alice gehabt, weil ich war ein halbes Jahr in Hamburg, aus gewissen Gründen, naja, hab ich ja schon mal erzählt. Und da war das so, dass das damals noch Hansenet da gerade richtig am Absahnen hatte und in den diversen WGs, in denen ich gewohnt hab, die hatten alle Hansenet.
Weil billig und einfach.
Weil billig und einfach. Einfach kündbar zum Monatsende. Die waren auch einfach viel fitter damals noch. Also auch was Carsten erzählt hat. Die waren am Anfang, waren die wirklich viel fitter, die waren viel freundlicher. Entschuldigung Clemens. Und deswegen, ich bin dann zurück nach Berlin gekommen. Ich hatte mein Berliner Telekom DSL irgendwas dann irgendwann mal abgemeldet. Auch den gesamten Telefonanschluss komplett abgemeldet. Und hab dann neu angemeldet und hab das über Alice gemacht. Und die haben damals, weil sie keine Ahnung, nicht genug Geräte am Start hatten oder weiß ich nicht wieso, die haben mir direkt eine Fritzbox gegeben. Und dann stöpsel ich diese Fritzbox an und dann stand da halt 8 Megabit. Stand in der Fritzbox drin.
Möglich oder vorhanden?
Stand Leitung 8 Megabit. Und dann hatten die den Traffic Shaper nicht am Start, keine Ahnung. Die war einfach offen die Leitung. Die hatten mir zwar nicht so viel zugesichert, aber die Leitung war einfach offen die ersten Wochen.
Was hatten sie denn zugesichert?
Achso, so richtig dieses Early Early 1024 1 Megabit DSL. Reden wir davon.
Ja, irgendwie sowas. Und die Leitung war einfach offen. Diese 8 Megabit gingen einfach durch diese Leitung durch. Die hatten es halt überhaupt noch nicht im Griff. Oh man. Und das war dann schon gut. Das ist ein bisschen schade, wenn man das ein paar Wochen hat und plötzlich greift dann doch irgendwie die Drossel. Aber am Anfang? Keine Ahnung. Da hatten sie wahrscheinlich gerade angefangen, hatten gerade mal Leitungen angemietet, die waren eh leer. Und dann war es halt auch egal. Ja, deswegen, ich kenne dieses Menü auch sehr gut, wo man da so gucken kann und er zeigt diese schöne Kurve an.
Die Kommentarfelder, der Kommentarbereich für diesen Podcast hat sich auch schon zu einem interessanten DSL Support Forum entwickelt. Da geht es irgendwie hoch her. Es gab auch schon erste Erfolgsmeldungen von Leuten, die dann tatsächlich auf Basis der Argumentationssicherheit, die sie durch den Podcast gewonnen haben, sich jetzt schnellere Leitungen abschalten lassen. Ich fand, ich fahre das Händelager und so.
Also ich habe das Problem, dass bei mir kommen über die Leitungen über nur, also manchmal auch mehr, aber so im Großen und Ganzen nur 1,3 Megabyte pro Sekunde. So, ich dachte am Anfang, das wäre vielleicht mein lahmes WLAN, aber das ist offensichtlich nicht, weil über WLAN kriege ich deutlich mehr. Ja, und jetzt probiere ich noch was zu kriegen, woran das liegt.
Was ich super fand, war, wie er da gemeint hat, ja Anfang der 90er Jahre war das, glaube ich. Anfang, Mitte der 90er Jahre haben alle in Europa noch gedacht, ISO, OSI-Modell, das ist doch das wahre und dieses dämliche Internet. Und ich habe ja Elektrotechnik studiert.
Ich glaube, das denken die bei der Telekom bis heute.
Und da war das an der TU in den Vorlesungen auch immer noch so heiliges OSI-Modell, heilige sieben Layer und was haben wir da gelernt? Wir haben diesen ganzen ATM-Scheiß, seitenweise, diese Abkürzungen von diesen, die sind in Layern und dann in Scheibchen, die Layern nochmal in Scheibchen und das war ein irrsinn.
Na gut, ATM ist immer noch aktuell.
ATM ist immer noch aktuell, ISDN war ja noch das gleiche. Also das ist ja ein Standard, der hat ja gar keine N, also der ist ja so riesig, das ist unglaublich. Gut, das Einzige, was man bei ISDN wirklich sagen muss, du hast halt eine Latenz, wenn du das richtige Equipment auf der Strecke hast, hast du eine Latenz, die ist unglaublich niedrig. Ist halt nur so ein paar Sample groß.
Ja, die ist ganz toll, das ist ja auch mit meinem ISDN-Kolleg immer eine wahre Freude, wenn ich mal... Ja, ich hab mir hier so einfach bei Ebay so ein ISDN-Kolleg geschoppt und wenn ich dann so ab und zu mal hier für Interviews angefragt werde in öffentlich-rechtliche Anstalten, dann kann ich mich halt damit verbinden.
Jaja, klar.
Ich bin halt irgendwie schön latenzfrei in korrekter Qualität verbunden und nicht hier irgendwie telefoniert. Aber wir...
Wir gleiten wieder ab.
Wir gleiten wieder sehr weit ab. Ich wollt auf jeden Fall für alle, die es noch nicht mitbekommen haben, mal diesen CAE hier pluggen, weil da ist einfach eine Menge drin. Und wenn ihr Ärger mit eurem DSL habt oder euch schon immer mal gefragt habt, warum es eigentlich kein schnelles Internet gibt, da wo ihr wohnt, da könnt ihr die Sendung euch interessante Einblicke bieten.
Ja, rechtlich die Andi ist gut.
So, und ich bin jetzt eigentlich auch so ein bisschen durch hier mit meinen Themen. Haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen? Ich würde heute auch gerne ehrlich gesagt nicht so mega lange machen, weil ich gerade so einen total rockigen 4-Tage-Dauereinsatz vor mir habe.
Also ich würde eine Sache gerne noch machen, die ich halt auch so ein bisschen vorbereitet hab.
Ja?
Das ist der große Vergleichstest TomTom gegen Navigon auf dem iPhone.
Das hast du gemacht und du hast beide gekauft.
Ich hab beide.
Oha.
Und hab beide auch eine längere Zeit im Einsatz gehabt. Und mir so meine Meinung gebildet.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Also grundsätzlich ist es so, sie taugen beide, wenn man mit dem Auto mal irgendwo hinfahren muss. Das ist so, da kann man eigentlich nichts sagen. Bei beiden ist das User-Interface gewöhnungsbedürftig. Gut, TomTom hat jetzt in der letzten Version noch mal ein bisschen umgeräumt, aber es ist trotzdem gewöhnungsbedürftig. Also einfach bei beiden.
Navigon hat auch ein bisschen umgeräumt in der letzten Version.
Navigon hat auch ein bisschen umgeräumt. Ja, Navigon hat jetzt vor allen Dingen in der letzten Version eingeführt, dass man Karten runterladen kann. Du kriegst also nur noch die nackte App, kriegst eine Liste von Karten, die du laden kannst, und kannst sie dann einzeln in die Länder runterladen, die du haben willst. Was ganz so?
Mach den initialen Download auf jeden Fall schon mal fixer.
Mach den initialen Download fixer und mach jetzt auch den Speicherbedarf auf dem Device niedriger, wenn man jetzt halt, ich sag mal, Frankreich und Italien jetzt gerade mal nicht braucht und Großbritannien vielleicht auch nicht. Aber wenn man da in den Urlaub fährt, dann kann man es immer noch runterladen. So. Na, fangen wir mal an mit dem Routing.
Was machst du denn so für Touren? Machst du jetzt nur so Stadt oder auch?
Ja, das sind eigentlich nur Beobachtungen innerhalb von Berlin, aber ich glaube, das Routing innerhalb von Berlin ist komplex genug, als dass man es auch auf andere Touren ausdehnen kann.
Ja gut, Autobahnen haben noch mal ihre eigenen Herausforderungen.
Da würde ich sagen, ist Navigon ein bisschen besser. Allerdings nimmt sich das nichts. Was ich interessant finde bei TomTom ist, dass sie so ein starkes Gewicht auf den Status einer Straße legen. Also wenn eine Straße Bundesstraße heißt, dann routet dich TomTom über diese Bundesstraße, weil es muss ja schneller gehen. Es ist ja eine Bundesstraße. Ähnliches gilt auch für Autobahnen. Es gibt da unten im Wannsee die Ecke, gibt es so ein Pseudo-Autobahn-Kreuz. Das ist eigentlich eine Auffahrt auf eine Autobahn, aber das ist so gemacht wie so ein Autobahn-Kleeblatt. Und man kann rechts rausfahren, parallel zur Bundesstraße auf dem, was eigentlich die Auffahrt zur Autobahn wäre, und dann wieder zurück auf die Bundesstraße fahren. Und weil aber dieses Stück Straße schon als Autobahn gilt, will einem Tom-Tom immer über dieses Stück Straße führen.
Obwohl da auch 50 erlaubt ist.
Das ist einfach besser versiegelt.
Das ist großartig. Es gab ja angeblich meine Zeit, da war da an diesem Stück 70 erlaubt. Da konnte man dann, also tatsächlich für 100 Meter, konnte man dann 70 fahren statt 50. Aber das ist nicht mehr. Also es ist nicht sinnvoll da abzufahren und dann wieder...
Lass mich mal ganz kurz, nur mal jetzt hier so an den Chat. Welcher Bild ist denn dieses 10-7-3? Ist das 11D50? Weil dann würde ich mir einfach aus dem Defzern da runterladen, die Version.
Jetzt darfst du weitermachen.
So, alles zum Routing, zum Renderer. Die Darstellung ist schon ein bisschen anders. Ich würde sagen, der Navigon-Renderer ist ein bisschen besser. Weil der auch richtige Kurven kann. Während der TomTom-Renderer, der setzt seine Straßen immer nur aus geraden Stücken zusammen. Die sind immer so ein bisschen eckig. Aber... Navigon blendet einem extrem viel Zeug ein. Jeder Aldi, jeder Lidl, jede Sparkasse, jede haste nicht gesehen mit einem kleinen Icon. Und zwar so richtig den gesamten Bildschirm zu. Das ist total nervig.
Das lässt sich aber auch ein bisschen konfigurieren, oder?
Das lässt sich ein bisschen konfigurieren. Du hast dann so eine Liste von 70 Items, wo am Anfang erst mal so Sachen stehen, die es nur in Amiland gibt. Und so ein Elektronikpartner ist auch immer angegeben. Also das nervt mich ohne Ende. Das ist das eine. Und das Zweite, das finde ich eigentlich noch viel besser. Navigon beherrscht kein scharfes S. Oder es ist nicht in der Datenbank drin. Keine Ahnung. Also sie schreiben halt 90 Prozent der Straßen falsch, weil sie diese Straße schreiben. Umlaut können sie aber, kein scharfes S.
Aber mein TomTom wiederum, wenn ich da was in meine... Also ich habe TomTom wie gesagt nicht auf dem iPhone, sondern so richtig im Auto. Wenn ich da versuche, einen Favoriten abzuspeichern und ich will ein SS haben, dann macht er mir aus dem SS immer ein SZ. Schon ein bisschen schräg.
Auch gut. Also das ist ein bisschen merkwürdig. Insofern würde ich sagen, Navigon sieht zwar ein bisschen besser aus, aber gefallen tut mir das nicht. So, jetzt muss ich mal gucken. Jetzt wird's... Ja, genau, dann gibt's jede Menge Absurditäten. Also TomTom fängt erst an zu routen, wenn er einen GPS-Fix hat. Das heißt, wenn wir in der Wohnung stehen... Das macht Navigon aber auch. Ja, aber Navigon geht dann in so einen komischen Simulationsmodus.
Das ist so pain in the ass. Du fängst irgendwo an, startest eine Navigation. Wir konnten keinen GPS-Fix finden. Sollen wir stattdessen eine Simulation einer Navigation starten?
Dann fühlst du dich so, wenn du so was aufgefährst.
Dann warte, bis du einen Fix hast und fang an mich zu... Was ist denn da? Also ich meine, wer denkt sich das aus?
Ja, aber bei TomTom ist es so, dass er halt einfach nichts macht. Der Bildschirm ist halt dann so in Graustufen, kein GPS und er tut gar nichts. Also er sagt nicht mal...
Na was soll er denn tun?
Wenn ich jetzt, also von der letzten bekannten Position, wenn ich jetzt losfahren würde, dann käme ich dann und dann an. Weißt du, so nach der Art irgendwie...
Aber mein festes TomTom macht das. Wunder mich jetzt ein bisschen.
Das ist irgendwie, das ist ein bisschen unklar. Das ist, naja, was habe ich denn hier noch? Geschwindigkeitswarnung. Sowas gibt es ja auch immer.
Ja, ist das eigentlich bei TomTom dabei oder muss man das wieder kaufen?
Nee, nee, das ist dabei. Was nicht dabei ist, sind die Radarfallen. Also die Warnung vor, da ist jetzt tatsächlich...
Achso, du fährst zu schnell versus Tralala.
Jaja, einfach nur die Geschwindigkeitswarnung, die haben ja beide in ihren Straßendaten, steht ja drin, wie die Höchstgeschwindigkeit ist und der sagt dir, wenn du zu schnell bist.
Die nicht immer stimmt.
Die nicht immer stimmt, du weißt es im Großen und Ganzen.
Ja, die schon häufig falsch ist. Also da hab ich so meine Erfahrungen gesammelt. Sowohl mit Navigon als auch mit TomTom. Die liegen nicht immer richtig.
Ja, die liegen nicht immer richtig. Ich finde es jetzt, also so die Bereiche, wo jetzt nicht gerade Baustellen sind, sind okay, finde ich. Na egal, wie dem auch sei. Navigon sagt nur einmal Achtung. Achtung. Achtung. Und bei TomTom kann ich mir einen Sound aussuchen. Aus einer Auswahl von 12 Sounds. Und da sind eigentlich ein paar ganz coole dabei. Vor allen Dingen das Gute daran ist, du hast einen markanten Sound, der dir sagt, du bist jetzt zu schnell. Nicht dieses Achtung, was man halt auch mal überhört, sondern hast diesen...
Funktioniert ganz gut.
Ich weiß nicht, finde ich...
Aber es ist sicherlich kein Fehler, wenn man das irgendwie setzen kann.
Das stimmt.
Was mich am meisten nervt an dem Navigon.
Navigon ist im direkten Vergleich immer ein bisschen optimistisch, was die Fahrzeit anbelangt. Da ist TomTom eher ein bisschen...
Hast du zwei iPhones nebeneinander gehalten, oder?
Nö, das ist von iPad.
TomTom ist relativ akkurat, das stimmt.
Ja, naja, ich meine, bei Navigon ist das Adressbuch extrem gut versteckt, hatte ich das Gefühl. Also wenn man eine Adresse aus dem eigenen Adresse... Wer kommt auf so eine Idee? Anfahren möchte, da ist man ein bisschen am Suchen, obwohl das jetzt bei... naja doch, bei TomTom ist es okay. Was ich bei Navigon auch cool finde, Audio ist einzeln regelbar. Also du kannst ja die iPod-App von Apple anwerfen und kannst Sound anmachen.
Und kannst dann bei Navigon die Stimme einzeln regeln im Verhältnis zu der Lautstärke von der iPod-App. Das ist, wenn man sehr leise Sachen oder sehr laute Sachen hat, ist das sinnvoll. Das geht bei TomTom leider nicht.
Ich hab vor allem sehr merkwürdige Ergebnisse und ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau, woran es eigentlich liegt. Meine Vermutung, nachdem ich ein bisschen diskutiert habe, ist, dass es unter Umständen auch an iOS liegen könnte. Aber wenn ich jetzt Navigon habe und eine Podcast ab, also in dem Fall vor allem Instacast habe ich getestet, also eine Third-Party-App, nicht die iPod-Anwendung, spielt Audio ab und ich hab parallel Navigon. Dann kommt Navigon immer mit seinen Ansagen dazwischen und unterbricht natürlich mit jeder Ansage den Podcast vollständig. Das heißt, er wird angehalten und dann so in 300 Metern biegen sie rechts ab oder so. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie der Navigon-Gesprächsstil ist. Ich hab immer diesen Tom-Tom irgendwie im Kopf. So, und dann fertig, dann noch mal so ein bisschen 21. Dann kommt dann diese Ab. Und nach dem vierten oder fünften oder sechsten Mal irgendwann geht es dann nicht wieder weiter. Und ich muss erst in die Ab wechseln und dann geht es auf einmal los. Also es ist nicht so, dass er glaubt, er sei angehalten, sondern er kommt irgendwie nicht in Wallung. Und das Hineinwechseln aktiviert diese Ab. Also das ist so, ich hab so die Vermutung, dass dieser Hintergrundprozess, der das Audio abspielt oder wieder aufnimmt, dass der einfach gekillt wird oder stirbt, auch wegen Timeout. Und dann ist es auch so absurd, wenn ich dann in der anderen Ab, in dem Fall dann Instacast, irgendwie rumwurstel und mir dann, was weiß ich, wieder irgendwie was zusammensuche oder den Podcast nochmal neu starten muss oder irgendwas tue. Was mal geil ist, während man gerade so Auto fährt, sich gerade mit solchen Sachen auseinanderzusetzen. Das will man ja nicht unbedingt. So, dann irgendwann fertig, läuft wieder, zurück in den Navigon ab, wechseln. Und dann haben sich irgendwie durch das Fahren verschiedene Ansagen aufgestaut. Also man ist irgendwie schon wieder so ein paar Ecken weiter. Und dann besteht er darauf, mir alles nochmal zu erzählen, auch wenn das schon längst hinter mir liegt. Und zwar hintereinander weg.
Also er macht dann seine Ansagen?
Ja, biegen sie rechts ab, biegen sie links ab, biegen sie rechts ab, biegen sie links ab. Irgendwie so, fahren sie diese Ausfahrt mit folgendem Namen und dann so erzähl, erzähl, erzähl. Ja, da war ich vor fünf Minuten irgendwie. Halt's Maul. Das ist furchtbar. Ich weiß nicht, warum sie das cueen. Also das scheint mir dann doch eher ein Fehler in der App zu sein. Also dieses ganze Zusammenspiel, Third-Party-Applikationen und Audio gegenseitig unterbrechen unter sich, das scheint mir auch unter iOS generell noch nicht sehr rund zu sein.
Also Hintergrund-Audio in iOS-Apps ist, glaube ich, auch ein großer Schmerz für die Entwickler.
Oh ja, den Eindruck hab ich auch.
Hintergrund-Audio?
Hintergrund-Audio in iOS-Apps ist, glaube ich, ein großer Schmerz für die Entwickler, weil du hast immer das Problem, dass hier unter iOS, wenn du in den Hintergrund gehst, wird dir die App immer so halbgekillt. Also der Main-Thread geht weg, aber irgendwelche komischen Hintergrund-Threads, die noch irgendwas machen, gehen dann gerne mal, laufen weiter und so. Also das ist irgendwie, das könnte ich verstehen, dass es dann nicht unbedingt ein Problem jetzt ist von Instacast, oder ein Problem von Navigon oder so, sondern das ist halt einfach dieses Prinzipielle mit diesem ganzen AV-Media-Gedöns, das ist...
Auch mal eine Verbutung, aber beweisen lässt sich das schwerlich. Und hast du dein 10.7.3. jetzt schon drauf, Max?
Ah, nee, ich lad noch grad das Combo-Update runter irgendwie.
Das Combo-Update?
Ja, ja, bei mir, Marc, wobei mir ist auch neulich aufgefallen, dass ich irgendwie eine andere Bildversion von 10.7.3. habe als andere Leute, die ist minimal neuer. Also, welcher hast du, was hast du jetzt für ein 10.7.2 drauf? 74? Ich hab die 71, keine Ahnung warum.
Auf einem, haben wir dasselbe Modell?
Ja, ich hab 13 Zoll. Also ich hab hier 1,8 GHz Intel Core i7. Nee, das ist die 74, die haben alle. Also ich hab irgendwie eine etwas ältere, keine Ahnung warum, Version von 10.7.2 drauf.
Wie läuft die gut? Kann ich die ja haben?
Na ich bügle gleich 10.7.3 drüber.
Dann weiß der Geier, was das wieder für ein Bild ist bei dir.
Na jetzt hab ich halt die Combo-Update-Seite. Ich vermute mal, dass er mir deswegen jetzt das Update nicht vorgeschlagen hat.
Also und last but not least die Staumeldungen.
Du warst noch nicht fertig?
Ich war noch nicht ganz fertig. Last but not least die Staumeldungen. Da muss ich sagen, da würde ich klar für TomTom voten. Also mir ist das, was Navigon macht, so völlig unklar. Der sagt dann irgendwann, ja es gibt so und so viel Warnungen auf der Strecke und ich zeig dir in fünf Sekunden irgendwas an und wenn man irgendwo draufdrückt, dann kriegt man so eine Karte in schwarz mit irgendwie, dann ist da irgendwas und das ist völlig unklar. Und bei TomTom hat man halt rechts diese Leiste, wo unten die, ich glaube unten ist es, unten ist die Position, wo man gerade ist und irgendwo oben ist das Ziel und man sieht dann, in so und so vielen Kilometern habe ich das und das Problem und das ist dann mit gelben, orangen oder roten Böpeln und dann kann ich sagen, jetzt neu routen, um das Problem zu entgehen oder eben nicht. Und vor allen Dingen habe ich das Gefühl, dass TomTom aktueller ist. Also Navigon gibt gerne mal Stauwarnungen aus und dann kommt man dahin und da ist ja nichts.
Und bei TomTom sagt er...
TomTom sagt, in drei Kilometern, zwei Minuten Verzögerung, dann hängst du drin, dann kannst du gar nicht so schnell gucken, dann hängst du in diesem verdammten Stau.
TomTom, die haben doch dieses mit Vodafone, diese Kooperation, dass sie deine Daten abschneucheln.
Dass sie alle Daten von allen Leuten abschneucheln.
Von allen Vodafone-Kunden.
Und das funktioniert wirklich gut. Na ja, man kann jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob das eine gute Sache ist oder nicht. Aber man muss ihnen zugestehen, es funktioniert. Es funktioniert verdammt gut.
Also, was ein bisschen in Richtung Navigationsgeräte geht, ich war über Weihnachten, da hatte ich einen Mietwagen. Ich hatte diverse Zigarettenanzünder-Ladegeräte, da gibt es ja auch keins, was so richtig gut funktioniert. Also das, was am besten funktioniert, das war, als ich mal vergessen hatte, eins zu kaufen, was ich dann so auf der Autobahn rasch gegriffen habe, an irgendeiner Tankstelle, was da zu kaufen gab, und dann hab ich das mitgenommen, das hat irgendwie 5 Euro gekostet oder so was. Und ich hab das, was ich jetzt dabei hatte, das ist von Hama. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gleiche Problem kennt, ich hab von Hama schon so viele Produkte von denen gekauft. Ich hab wirklich noch nie eins gehabt, was nicht auf ganzer Linie versagt hat. Und bei diesem Hama-Ladegerät ist das so, steckst du rein und sobald du das an dein iPhone anschließt, glaubt dein iPhone, dass dieses Ladegerät auch Kopfhörer, also Soundausgang hätte. Was dazu führt, dass wenn man navigieren will damit, dass man einfach komplett ohne Tonausgabe navigieren muss. Ich weiß nicht, was die bei Hama reitet.
Da gibt es da mal keinen Link hin, apropos Ladegeräte. Ich hab da ja dann noch ein bisschen investiert. Es gibt von TomTom gibt es noch so einen Navi-Halter fürs iPhone, wo nochmal ein einzelner GPS-Empfänger drin ist. Da ist irgendwie noch ein Lautsprecher drin und ein GPS-Empfänger. Das sind einfach Unterschiede wie Tag und Nacht. Ich weiß nicht wieso dieser GPS-Empfänger so deutlich besser ist, als das eingebaute Teil vom iPhone. Aber du merkst, dass wenn man jetzt Navigon benutzt, mit dem gleichen Halter, der halt auch die GPS-Daten von dem eingebauten Halter nicht lesen kann, dass der öfter mal halt keinen Fix hat. Und TomTom mit dem Teil zusammen einfach solide. Ich hab das noch nie groß erlebt, dass er gut fest im Tunnel rein. Aber ansonsten hat er immer Fix, immer in der Stadt.
Das mit dem Tunnel wiederum verstehe ich nicht, warum sie das nicht hinkriegen.
Wieso?
Müssten sie nicht eigentlich die Beschleunigungssensoren ganz gut auslesen können?
Um dann zu sagen, du wirst langsamer und bist jetzt langsweit im Tunnel.
Naja, ich meine das Telefon wird doch, oder sehe ich gerade irgendwas falsch? Ich meine das Telefon wird...
Wenigstens grob schätzen. Ingenieur meint, du wirst es wahrscheinlich auch tun.
Beide Programme extrapolieren deine Geschwindigkeit, die du in den Tunnel hinein hattest. Ja, aber die Geschwindigkeit hast du doch. Ja, wenn du in den Tunnel reinfährst. Aber wenn du jetzt in einen Stau in einem Tunnel fährst...
Ja, aber dann merkst du doch, dass das iPhone sich nicht mehr bewegt. Ich würde gerne mal wissen, wie Beschleunigungssensoren. Ich meine, dafür sind sie doch da.
Ja, aber so genau sind die glaube ich nicht.
Zwischen Stau, also zwischen Stehen und 100 kmh wirst du sicherlich einen Unterschied merken.
Ja, aber du hast einmal die Beschleunigung der Abbremsung. Und danach hast du ja wieder keine Beschleunigung mehr. Weißt du, wenn der Tunnelschnur geradeaus ist und du gibst nicht Gas, fährst du immer mit gleicher Geschwindigkeit durch den Tunnel, dann...
Kriege ich keine Daten...
.misst der Beschleunigungssensor auch nichts anderes, als wenn du im Tunnel stehst. Nur den Übergang von ich fahre jetzt 100 und ich fahre null, das ist natürlich eine Beschleunigung. Weil du abbremst.
Okay, das stimmt natürlich.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass du das robust genug hinkriegst.
Hier steht, Navigon nutzt doch auch das TomTom Cradle.
Ja, das ist mir aber noch nicht aufgefallen. Kann natürlich sein, dass sie da inzwischen irgendwie... Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass Navigon da eher Probleme hat mit dem Empfang als TomTom. Vielleicht ist TomTom da auch ein bisschen großzügig, das die News an sich einzufangen.
Also wie gesagt, TomTom hab ich nur im Auto, da bin ich so naja mitzufrieden. Was ich gut fand jetzt bei Navigon war, dass er mir auch Straßennamen vorliest. Macht das das TomTom auch? Ja okay und so mit Fahrspuren anzeigen.
Ja macht er auch. Hab ich aber ausgemacht, weil ich das blöd finde. Ja ja doch macht er aber.
Ich finde das manchmal ganz praktisch bei so großen Kreuzen. Es gibt ja so Autobahnen.
Also bei Autobahnen finde ich das krass, dass der einem wirklich auch die Schilder anzeigt.
Ich meine, das ist ja technisch nicht viel, aber besonders krass, wenn da Flughafen Tempelhof draufsteht und du denkst, wie lange ist der Flughafen nicht mehr? Also mit Karten kann man viel Spaß haben.
Naja, wobei mit Karten muss ich jetzt mal sagen, mir ist neulich aufgefallen, auf Google Maps ist der Reichstag nicht drauf. Der fehlt einfach. Du siehst so Umrisse von allen Gebäuden und du siehst davon, wie heißt das Schlüterhaus und vom Bundeskanzleramt, aber der Reichstag fehlt einfach. Wenn du da entsprechend rein oder raus zoomst, ist da eine Markierung, dass er da sein müsste, aber das Gebäude fehlt.
Dieses Gebäude ist in ihrem Land nicht verfügbar.
Und auf Google Maps, die haben auch am Südring hier von, also der S-Bahn-Ring, der ist, war, jetzt ist er zu auf Google Maps, aber der war ewig bis vor zwei Monaten mindestens, war der nicht zu. Und das ist für Leute, die nicht in Berlin wohnen, der ist seit länger als es Google Maps gibt, ist dieser Ring bereits geschlossen. Also da ist einfach keine Eisenbahn eingebaut gewesen. Eingemacht gewesen. Ja, also so viel zum Thema Kartenmaterial. Und wir verlassen uns jeden Tag auf.
Ja, das Kartenmaterial, da muss man sagen, das ist bei beiden irgendwie, wenn da mal so eine Straße gebaut wird, dann braucht es schon zwei, drei Jahre, bis es im Kartenmaterial ankommt.
Das ist echt krass.
Das ist, aber da nehmen die sich auch beide nichts. Da gab es jetzt irgendwie nördlich vom Südbahnhof gibt es so eine Straße, die da neu gebaut wurde und die hat, ich glaube TomTom hat sie jetzt, aber Navigon noch nicht. Dafür hat Navigon irgendwie eine Straße, die da irgendwo im Wedding neu ist. Also das ist irgendwie.
So Jungs, haben wir es?
Ja, das nächste Mal kann ich mich ein bisschen, das Huckel hoffentlich wieder da, da kann ich mich ein bisschen mit ihm über Rails prügeln.
Wir merken das schon mal vor.
Ich hab mir jetzt ja Rails ein bisschen drauf geschafft.
Ansonsten machen wir jetzt hier eine schöne Mac OS 10.10.7.3 Install-Party.
Ich brauche hier noch zwei Minuten.
Und ich den Podcast raushole.
Bis das hier gedownloaded ist.
Und nochmal ein bisschen Final Cut Pro X Updates hier einfahren.
Also meiner sagt aktualisierte Komponenten registrieren. Ich bin schon fast durch.
Machen wir uns hier so eine kleine Software-Update-Party.
Ja, und mir sagt mein Computer wieder, dass mein iCloud-Passwort irgendwie...
Und es steht drin, dass beim Wi-Fi Reconnection Problems on Wake Up sich das gesolved hat. Das ist so, oh, endlich. Das hat mich ja doch...
Bist du sicher, dass sie deine...
Ich hoffe.
Gesolft.
Wir werden mal sehen.
Gut, das war's. Unsere 80. Ausgabe. Aber es wird nicht die letzte bleiben. Wir haben die Termine für die nächsten Sendungen auch schon alle fein kommuniziert auf mobilemax.de, search live. Da könnt ihr auch alle anderen Informationen finden, die euch schon noch nie interessiert haben. Rund ums Team, unsere nächsten Termine und natürlich auch immer die tollen Show-Notes mit Links auf alles Mögliche.
Und noch mal als Tipp, m.google.com/sync, dann Sprache auf Englisch sprichend dran und dann wird dein Kalender einsteigen. Mehr braucht man nicht zu wissen.
Mehr braucht man nicht zu wissen.
Wir haben über Kalender geredet.
Ja und Tim hat nicht mal einen Blubdruck bekommen.